COMMITTEE TO PORTER. AND JUST
MEMBERS WE HAVE A QUORUM HERE
SOON AS I GET THROUGH WITH
THIS- THE PROCEDURES WERE GOING
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND- AND
DO THE CONSENT AGENDA AND WE
HAVE HAD THREE BILLS. BOB HOLD
OR POSTPONED FROM TODAY'S
AGENDA SO- WE WILL HAVE
FOURTEEN BILLS AND SIX AROUND
CONSENT WHEN WE GET TO THE
SERVER- LET ME JUST REMIND
EVERYONE. THAT IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING CENTERED HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTRICT DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OF OUR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY- THE
MEMBERS THAT WE EXPECT TO
ATTEND REMOTELY TODAY. OR
SENATOR REALLY MOAN AND SENATOR
STERN AND I DO SEE THAT CENTER
GIRLY MOUND IS WITH US SO. LET
ME RECOGNIZE YOU AND IF YOU
COULD- IDENTIFY. YOUR STAFF
MEMBER THAT IS WITH YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATE EARLY MOUNTAIN
IN DISTRICT OFFICE AND THE
STAFF MEMBER AS AND SHORTY
SCULLY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOU DOING THAT IN
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE. AND
LET ME REMIND THE SENATORS AS A
REMINDER TO MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS CONSISTS WILL BE
GREATLY HELPFUL NO ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO. BE RECOGNIZED
YOU CAN USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM ALTHOUGH
I KNOW SENATOR WE MOM TAX
FREQUENTLY AND THAT IS WELCOME
BY THE CHAIR AS WELL. EACH TIME
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU'VE BEEN SPEAKING ARE
I. T. PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
SOCIAL. DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW- AND TODAY THAT'S THIS
HEARING ROOM- THIS HEARING ROOM
A FORTY TWO OH THREE AND THEN
ALSO ROOM TWENTY FORTY- THEN-
HELLO WE WILL ALSO HAVE A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE FIVE FOUR NINE ZERO AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. NINE SEVEN SIX
THREE ZERO EIGHT SEVEN. IF YOU
NEED DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
MARKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT TO BE PROMPTED
BY MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
A PRESS THERE'S ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOUR LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WHITE ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LONG NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LONG NUMBER. THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE FINE MUTED AND
YOUR BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE AND JUST REMIND YOU
THAT WE WILL ON ME IF YOU FROM
THIS AND YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE
YOU'RE ON UNITS FROM YOUR
ACCOUNT. WILL BE. A MAC. OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
THEN OPPOSITION ON EACH BILL.
TO HEAR FROM AS MANY PEOPLE AS
TIME PERMITS WE ASK YOU TO
SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONCE AGAIN YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE IF YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING- AND- ON
FOR DINNER GIVEN TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU HAND THANK YOU
FOR THE PATIENCE THAT WILL BE
REQUIRED I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING A HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUSIC.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINED HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LIKE TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. ARE WE
NOW HAVE AS I SAID EARLIER
FOURTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA- FILE ITEMS ONE S. B.
TWENTY FIVE THREE SB FOUR
EIGHTY TWO AND EIGHT SB SIX
TWENTY SIX HAVE BEEN PULLED AT
THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST AND THEN
THERE ARE SIX BILLS ON PROPOSED
CONSENT FILE ITEMS. NINE TEN
TWELVE THIRTEEN SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN. BOB BEFORE WE GO TO
THE FIRST BILL- WHAT'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. LAYERED HERE
THERE TO HEAR JONES. JONES HERE
ALLEN. ALLEN HERE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE GROVE HERTZBERG
HUESO THEIR WAY SO HERE'S
LIMóN. INTERNING ON PRESIDENT
LOAN HERE STERN. OKAY WE HAVE
SIX MEMBERS PRESENT WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND BEFORE WE MOVE TO
THE FIRST BILL I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE SIX
ITEMS ARE NAMED ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA. MOVED BY HUESO. SIGNAL
DISCUSSION LET ME ASK YOU TO
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEM NINE SB THREE NINE
SIX FILE ITEM TEN S. B. FOUR
SIX THREE. FILE ITEM TWELVE S.
B. NINE ZERO I'M SORRY SB SEVEN
ZERO NINE FILE ITM THIRTEEN SB
SEVEN ONE SIX FILE TEM SIXTEEN
S. B. EIGHT TO ONE AND FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN. S. B. EIGHT TWO
TWO- LAYERED HI THERE ALL RIGHT
JONES JONES ALL RIGHT ALAN. HI
ALAN HI EGGMAN EGGMAN RA GROWS
HERTZBERG HUESO HI HUESO AYE
LIMóN. I LIMON R. A. STERN.
OKAY WE HAVE SIX VOTES WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL. PHONE THAT WOULD
BE ENOUGH. THE END OF WE WILL
BEGIN- TO GO TO THE BILLS THE
FIRST ONE IS FILE. ITEM TWO SB
SIX TWENTY FOUR SENATOR WHY SO
AND I THINK THAT IF YOU WOULD
LIKE ANY MEMBERS COULD PRESENT
FROM THE DIETS IN THE INTEREST
OF OUR CURRENT TO SO IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU'D LIKE TO DO. WELL YES
SIR MR CHIRLA COME TO YOUR
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ELECT TO A PRESENT HERE FROM
THE DIESTER AND I ALSO WANT TO
REITERATE- WHAT YOU ALREADY
SAID ABOUT SB. FOUR EIGHTY TWO
WE VOLUNTARILY POSTPONED THE
HEARING OF THAT BILL- TO UPDATE
ONLINE SO- I'LL BE PRESENTING
TO BILLS TODAY WITH THE CHAIRS
OF PERMISSION. THE FIRST ONE IS
SB SIX TWO FOUR WHAT WE'RE
CALLING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY IN OUTDOOR ACCESS ACT-
SO I FIRST OF ALL WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE AND MY STAFF AND
GLADLY ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. SB SIX TO FORCE A
BILL THAT SEEKS TO ESTABLISH
AND PROMOTE ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY AN OUTDOOR ACCESS PASS A
GOAL FOR ALL STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. THAT MANAGE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND SO IN ON
THE YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE THIS
HAS BEEN KIND OF A CONSTANT
THEME. IT'S KIND OF A CONSTANT
BATTLE HAVING TO- FIGHT EVERY
YEAR FOR EQUITY AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND I JUST THOUGHT.
THAT I'D SAVE EVERYONE A LOT OF
TROUBLE AT WORK ON A POLICY
THAT WILL REALLY GO ACROSS-
MANY DIFFERENT SEGMENTS OF OUR
SOCIETY AND WORK AT CREATING
EQUITY. AS SOMEBODY THAT WAS
RAISED IN AN UNDERSERVED AREA I
HAVE ALL THE BUT BUMPS AND
SCARS ON MY HEAD TO PROVE THAT
YOU KNOW MOST OF THE TIME. YOU
KNOW IT WAS VERY HARD TO ACCESS
TO PARKING IF WE DID THEY WERE
USUALLY SMALL PARKS INADEQUATE
FOR SPORT SPORTING ACTIVITIES-
WE MOSTLY PLAYED IN THE STREET
IN THE ASPHALT IN THE SIDEWALK
AND- I CAN'T. BEGIN TO DESCRIBE
ALL THE INJURIES I SUSTAINED
AND ALL THE KIDS OF MINOR
NEIGHBORHOOD SUSTAIN PLAYED
TACKLE FOR FOOTBALL AN ASPHALT
AND SOCCER THAN IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE. AND THAT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN ACROSS OUR STATE IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF SOCIETY WE
HAVE. PEOPLE RECREATION AND
DANGEROUS- THE STREETS AND IN-
AREAS- WITH LOTS LOTS OF
TRAFFIC AND MANY IN MANY CASES
ARE OUR POCKET PARKS IF THAT'S
ALL THEY HAVE ARE ARE NOT
REALLY SUITABLE. FOR CERTAIN
SPORTING ACTIVITIES. WE HAVE
WORKED OVER THE YEARS AND
MAKING OUR OUR COASTLINE MARC
SENSIBLE. ON MAKING OF PARKS
MORE ACCESSIBLE SO THIS BILL
WOULD- BUT WORK ON PROMOTING
EQUITY AND ENSURING ACCESS TO
THE STATE'S NATURAL RESOURCES
AND IT'S BEEN A TOP PRIORITY OF
THIS LEGISLATURE AT LEAST FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS I'VE BEEN
HERE BUT- AND WITH THERE HAS
BEEN OTHER LEGISLATION THAT
DEALS WITH WITH CERTAIN ASPECTS
OF THAT AND WE THOUGHT WE FILL
IN A LOT OF THE BLANKS OF.
PRIOR LEGISLATION SO. IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS STATE AGENCIES
HAVE TAKEN LARGE STRIDES IN
DEVELOPING AND DEDICATING.
RESOURCES TO- SEVERAL NEW AND
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS THERE IS
START. STILL AS I MENTIONED
MUCH WORK TO BE DONE. TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION AND ACCESS ARE ARE
TRULY PROVIDED. AS WE SAW WITH
THE COVERT. THE IMPACTS OF
COVERT AND THE STAY AT HOME
ORDER HAVE REALLY MAGNIFIED
OBSTACLES THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS FACED. ACCESSING
OUTDOOR SPACES AND RECREATION
FIRM FOR MANY COMMUNITIES IT
WAS MUCH HARDER TO ACCESS THESE
ESPECIALLY IN THE WAKE OF THE
ELIMINATION OF PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. AND OTHER OF.
OF TRANSPORTATION AMENITIES
THESE EQUITIES WERE WERE
DISPLAYED VERY CLEARLY AND
FAMILIES WHO ARE WISHING TO GO
OUTDOORS BUT DIDN'T HAVE A PARK
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE. OR
WERE DENIED ENTRY AT STATE
PARKS AND BEACHES AFTER
TRAVELING LONG DISTANCES TO
THEM. DURING THE PANDEMIC
RESTRICTIONS- THAT ONLY PERMIT
LOCAL LOCALS. DURING CERTAIN
TIMES MANY. OF MEMBERS OF MY
COMMUNITY THAT RELIED ON.
HAVING TO PLAN THESE EVENTS
WERE REALLY LEFT OUT AND-
DIDN'T HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE TO GO.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO EXPLICIT
AUTHORITY FOR STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS TO PROMOTE DRUM
FOR PROMOTE TO PROMOTE
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION.
BY ADDRESSING THE SPECIFIC
BARRIERS TO ACCESS FOR THE
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY LACKED OR FACE
DISPROPORTIONATE BARRIERS TO
ACCESS TO S. B. TWO FIVE SIX
TWO FOUR WOULD ADD A NEW
DIVISION TO THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE. TO ADDRESS THIS.
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
HAS STATED THAT LORD PARK
ACCESS IS ASSOCIATED WITH A
GREATER LIKELIHOOD OF BEING
OVERWEIGHT. FURNISHES THE SPURS
DISPARITIES ARE AFFECTING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
THROUGH THIS BILL WE ARE
SEEKING TO ACHIEVE
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY IN PROMOTE
EQUITABLE. EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT HAVE BEEN
LEFT WITH THE LEAST ACCESS TO
THE STATE'S NATURAL RESOURCES
ARE MOST VULNERABLE. TO
ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS THERE IS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AND LOOKED TO HAVE EVERYONE
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR WILL SPEAK WITH A MASS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR WATCH SO.
AND WE HAVE. TO- PEOPLE LISTED
AS LEAD SUPPORT BOTH THAT ARE
GOING TO BE ON THE CONFERENCE
LINE. WE'RE TRYING TO LIMIT TO
BOTH SPEAKERS TO FOUR MINUTES
TODAY EACH SIDE AND THEN WE
HAVE FIFTEEN MINUTES IF THERE
ARE A ME TOO SO LT'S GO FIRST
NOW WE HAVE LESS FOR DUNCAN
FROM OUTDOOR OUTREACH. AND
JAMIE GO FROM PARKS NOW- WHAT
STARK WITH WEST FOR DUNCAN IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. BECAUSE A LOT.
HE'S NOT ON THE LINE DO WE HAVE
FOR JAMIE GO ON A LONG. ALSO-
OKAY WELL BECAUSE THIS BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO GO AND IF THEY
SHOW UP WE WILL. A GUARD OUT SO
THIS WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANYONE TO. A SPEAKER ARE IN
SUPPORT. AND THIS WOULD JUST BE
A CHANCE TO PUT YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
SO MODERATOR UP COULD YOU QUEUE
UP ANYBODY THAT WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIX
TWO FOUR. YES MISTER
CHAIRPERSON IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE STATE SENATE
BILL SIX TWO FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAT DIDN'T ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE. WE'RE GONNA
GO THE LINE NUMBER THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT DID
DANIELLE LYNCH MAYBE MY LONG
LIST OF SUPPORTERS WILL GIVE
BLACKS DURING JAMIE OF HAVE
TIME TO CALL IN- EXPRESSING
POOR ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY ACT
THAT COALITION. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AS- AN
EMPLOYER WE CANNOT OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT LOS ANGELES
NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
NATURE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION WE'VE
TRANSPORTATION ORGANIZATION. A
CALL MY COMMUNITY CENTER YOU'RE
A BUSINESS COUNCIL INCLUSION
OUTDOORS AND TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND AGAIN ALL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE THAT
YOU SAVED US A LOT OF EXTRA
CALLS AND SENATOR HUESO IS
GRAYSON GRATEFUL FOR YOUR CALL
MODERATOR. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. YES MEXICO TO LINE UP
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS ONE OF THEM
YOU DON'T KNOW- WITH OTTOMAN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AND MISS
YOU GO TOLD ME THAT THE LINE IS
STUCK BEFORE THE TESTIMONY SO
I'M NOT SURE WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE. OKAY R. O. WE APPRECIATE
THAT WE WILL NOT UP WITH OUR I.
T. PEOPLE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
MINE THE STOCK BUT THAT MEANS
THAT. THEY WILL TRY TO ON
STICKERED SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALL- MODERATOR THE NEXT PERSON.
YES NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CAN DEL PINO
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY AND DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN LAZY
JAMMING UP YOUR IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX TWO FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON WITH NOBODY ELSE IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
FORGOT TO ASK IF THERE WAS
ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
THAT NEEDED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THAT BILL. AND I SEE NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SO FAR WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITE. SHE KNEW
GOING ON THE LINE NOW. THE N.
WHAT'S GO TO JAMIE GO 2% R. AS
A READ SUPPORT TO A WITNESS FOR
SB SIX TWENTY FOUR. YES GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS SORRY
ABOUT THE DELAY THERE WAS AN
ISSUE WITH THE ONLINE BUT
REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO YOU CAN SUPPORT
AND FIX TWENTY FOUR- AND JAMIE
ON BEHALF OF THE PARKS NOW
COALITION WE'RE A GROUP OF OVER
THIRTY ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE
THAT ARE. UNITED BY THE GOAL OF
PROMOTING THAT IN NATURE AND
ITS BENEFITS AND MANY OF OUR
COALITION MEMBERS HAVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING OUTDOORS IT
EXPERIENCES AND ACTIVITIES SO
WE KNOW WHAT. WHAT THE CRUCIAL
IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENJOY THE
OUTDOORS EXIST FOR EVERYONE AND
WE ALSO KNOW THAT OUTDOOR
SPACES AND RECREATION ARE STILL
NOT EQUALLY ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE SEEING
MORE CLEARLY BECAUSE OF THE
COVERAGE NINETEEN CAN THAT MAKE
BRING IT TO LIGHT IN A PRETTY
ON A NORMAL WAY. AND WHILE THE
STATE HAS MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS TOWARDS PROMOTING
EQUITABLE ACCESS THROUGH
STANDALONE POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS LIKE THE STATEWIDE
PARKS PROGRAMMED OUTDOOR EQUITY
GRANTS PROGRAM MUCH MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE AND IF YOU FEEL
APPROACH OF ADVANCING ACT BACK
THROUGH INDIVIDUAL POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS THAT AREN'T ALWAYS
LEVERAGED IS SHORT SIGHTED AND
KIND OF OVERLY COMPLICATED.
INSTEAD OF APPROACHING THINGS
THIS WAY AND YOU TRULY BILL TO
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT ACCESS AND EQUITY
ARE PRIORITIZED IN EVERY
SITUATION POSSIBLE AND SB SIX
TWENTY FOUR WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT WE DO THAT BY ESTABLISHING
THAT IT IS THE POLICY OF THE
STATE TO ENSURE ALL PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO THE STATE'S NATURAL.
AND CULTURAL RESOURCES. BASH
ATTENTION TO THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN DARK WE THINK. ACT THAT.
FURTHER IN THE BILL DON'T
EXPLICITLY AUTHORIZE THE NOT
REACHED EACH. AND THINKING HOW
UNDER IT TAKE THE ACT. I AND
REMOVE THE BARRIERS EQUITABLE.
PRIORITY THOSE THAT ARE ON
WRAPS. IN THE OUTDOORS. BY
DOING THAT THE BILL WOULD GIVE
THE AGE CLAY AND AUTHORITY TO
AMPLE TARGET STRATEGY THAT
PROMOTE ACT. AND EQUITY AND ALL
OF THEIR ACTIVITIES AND FURTHER
DIRECT. ACTIVELY WAYS AND YOU.
WHERE IT'S ALREADY IN THE WHERE
IT HAPPENING. READY TO REINVENT
WE WILL LIKE TO THANK SENATOR.
OVER HIS LEADERSHIP THE BILL
AND WE WERE- AND I. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH- NOW OUR WALL OF
TO WE HAD LEAD UP WE WENT TO
THE ROOM BACKUP ROOM AND- FOUND
FOR OTHERS. ONE GO TO OPERA IS
ANYBODY IN THE HEARING WHICH TO
ON OF TO SENATE BILL SIX FOUR.
ANYONE IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY. I
SEE NO ONE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP ANYBODY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ENTERED THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX TWO FOUR. YES THANK
YOU BASIN GENTLEMAN UP YOUR IN
OPPOSITION SB SIX TWO FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE CANNOT TWO ONE ZERO
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION SB. SIX
TWO FOUR. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
HOLY PAPER FIRST PERSON. AND I
APOLOGIZE MISTER PERSONAL BE
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. TO BE JUST
ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE. JUST
ANOTHER BALL THE. ORDER ONLINE.
YEAH IT'S JUST ONE MORE MOMENT
WITH. RIGHT. ANALYTICA PERSON
REMOVED HIMSELF Q. PLEASE GO
AHEAD MR CHAIRPERSON OKAY SO
WITH NO ONE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE TELECONFERENCE AND- THEN
THE MATTER IS BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SENATE BILL SIX
TWENTY FOUR DIFFERENT BODY OF
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. IS
ANYBODY MOTIVATED TO MAKE A
MOTION. THEN THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED DID THAT MEAN YOU HAD A
QUESTION THE CITY WAS IN A HE A
CENTER ALLEN HAS MOVED THE BILL
SENATOR HUESO YOU MAKE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT AND- I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF YOUR ADULT I THANK
YOU FOR. WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL- S. B. FILE ITEM TO SB
SIX TWO FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE. LAYERED HI ALL RIGHT
JONES JONES HI ALLEN ALLEN ALL
RIGHT EGGMAN. GROVE GROVE HI
HERTZBERG HUESO HI WE SAW OUR
IN THE MOMENT. BETTER THAN MY
OWN SB SIX TWO FOUR AYE MON AYE
STERN. OKAY THAT IS SIX VOTES I
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL. BEFORE
WE MOVED TO SENATOR Y. SO'S
NEXT BILL SB SIX OH FOUR LET ME
MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT. FOR
SENATORS AND PEOPLE LISTENING
ON THE PHONE WE HAVE TO TAKE
ONE BILL OUT OF ORDER. IN IN A
LITTLE WHILE WHEN THAT WILL BE
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SB SEVEN
NINE NINE SENATOR GLAZERS. SO
WHEN WE TAKE THAT OUT OF ORDER
I JUST WANT PEOPLE IN THE
LISTENING AUDIENCE TO KNOW THAT
YOU SHOULD HAVE YOUR TESTIMONY
READY. AND BE THERE AND WE
WILL- IF IT'S POSSIBLE WILL
TAKE IT UP AFTER THIS BILL BUT
WE'LL SEE WHERE WE ARE. SENATOR
WAY SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM FOR WHICH IS US
SENATE BILL SIX OH FOUR. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
AMONG ADULTS PRESENT SB SIX OH
FOUR OF A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE STATES CONSERVANCIES.
AND THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD TO ESTABLISH. GRANT
PROGRAMS TO FUND CLIMATE
MITIGATION ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE AS WELL AS OTHER
CLIMATE EMERGENCY PROJECTS.
THAT SUPPORT OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE RESILIENCY EFFORTS
WHILE PROVIDING ACCESS TO
NATURAL RESOURCES ITS CAREERS.
CALIFORNIANS WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT OVER NINETEEN IS
EXACERBATED ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY IN IN WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. THESE ARE THE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE OFTEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
FOR REFERENCE CALIFORNIA'S
FOURTH FOURTH CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENT. WAS RELEASED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND A PROJECTED
THAT THE COSTS ARE TO THE STATE
ASSOCIATED WITH DIRECT CLIMATE
IMPACTS. WHICH ARE PROJECTED-
THE IMPACTS TO BE IN THE TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BY
TWENTY FIFTY. THE EMPOWERMENT
OF WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCY EFFORTS MEN AND
WOMEN IN THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
FACED EXCLUSIONARY HI CORINNE
AND EDUCATIONAL. EDUCATIONAL
PRACTICES THAT HAVE PUT THEM AT-A SIGNIFICANT DISADVANTAGE IN
THE JOB MARKET AND THE ECONOMY
AT LARGE TO ADDRESS ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF COVER NINETEEN AND
CLIMATE CHANGE CURRENTLY TWO OF
THE NATION'S MOST PRESSING
ISSUES. WE MUST INVEST IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CLIMATE
BENEFICIAL PROJECTS AND HIGH
QUALITY WELL PAID WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS TO
INTRODUCE REAL JOBS TO THE
GREEN ECONOMY OF OUR STATE. BY
REQUIRING THE STATE
CONSERVANCIES IN THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD TO ESTABLISH
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY PROJECTS. THAT
SPECIFIED UNDER SB SIX OH FOR
CALIFORNIA COULD ADDRESS THE
NEED TO INVEST IN OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE PREPAREDNESS
CAPABILITIES WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY FACILITATING
HANDS ON TRAINING CERTIFICATION
AND HIGH ROAD JOB PLACEMENT
SERVICES. IN THE CABIN FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT. WE HAVE WITNESSES
TODAY ALEXANDER COURT GONZALEZ
IS A CORE MEMBER WITH THE GREEN
VALLEY CONSERVATION CORPS WE
ALSO HAVE FERNANDO GOMES CAESAR
RANGER- WITH THE MOUNTAINS
RECREATION AND CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY. WITH THE PERMISSION
OF THE CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER WAY SO WE WILL
MOVE TO WE HAVE THOSE TOO- OUR
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES
ALEJANDRO GONZALEZ AND FERNANDO
GOMEZ THEY'RE EACH GOING TO BE
JOINING US ON THE CONFERENCE
LINE WILL BEGIN IF HE'S THERE
WITH HOW HAND TROPE AND SALAS.
GOOD MORNING MR SHARE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS THE KEEPER OF THE
COORDINATOR FOR THE GREATER
VALUE CONSERVATION CORPS GBTC
IS ONE OF FOURTEEN LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE THE ONLY
CONSERVATION CORPS THAT
OPERATED. BY COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION PROGRAM D. SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY UP EDUCATION.
COMMITTEE ARE USED BETWEEN
YOUTH BETWEEN THE AGES OF
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE TO
WORK IN A RECYCLING AND NATURAL
REASON. GEN THE COURT OFFERS
AND EARN WHILE YOU LEARN
OPPORTUNITY ON THE JOB TRAINING
INDUSTRY RECOGNIZED
CERTIFICATIONS CAREER
DEVELOPMENT ADULT EDUCATION
NEEDED IN POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. READ ABOUT
THE CONSERVATION CORPS IS
CURRENTLY COVERS FIVE COUNTY.
SAN JOAQUIN STANISLAUS
CALAVERAS AMADOR TO ONLY WE
HAVE TWO LOCATIONS ONE IN STOCK
IN ONE OF SONORA OUR GOAL IS TO
PROVIDE SUCCESSFUL PATHWAYS FOR
YOUTH. AND SUPPORT A WIDE
VARIETY OF CONSERVATION AND
CLIMATE AWARENESS PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT OUR REGION. WITH ME
TODAY IS ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
ALESSANDRO GONZALEZ AND HE WILL
BE PROVIDING SOME TESTIMONY
DETAILING HIS EXPERIENCES WITH
OUR PROGRAM. WITHOUT YOUR CELL
HUNDRED. HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
MY IS A LOT AND ALL I TWENTY
TWO YEARS OLD. AND I LIVE IN
WEST ATTENTION I AM A CORE
MEMBER HERE RALLY COUNTRY CORPS.
SO BACK IN JUNE OR RATHER
BACKING TWENTY NINETEEN I WAS
LOOKING FOR A JOB THAT WOULD
WORK WELL AROUND MY SCHEDULE
NOT ONLY THAT BUT ALSO A JOB
THAT WOULD TEACH ME. HILLS AND
WHATNOT SO THANKS TO A FRIEND
THAT WAS ALREADY WORKING AT UTC
I WAS ABLE TO GET IN. AND MY
TYPICAL WEEK AT UBC I WOULD GO
TO SCHOOL ADULTS- MONDAY
WEDNESDAY. FRIDAY AND ON
TUESDAYS AND THURSDAYS I WORK
HERE AS WELL AS ON WEEKENDS.
AND THANKS TO THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE
I WAS ABLE TO TAKE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND CAREER
DEVELOPMENT CLASSES- AND I WAS
ABLE TO LEARN THINGS LIKE
LANDSCAPER GEISHA AND- HOW TO
WRITE A RESUME. INTERVIEW FOR A
JOB- I WORK IN- ON IRRIGATION
I'VE I'VE DONE SHE LOAD
REDUCTION. AND LANDSCAPE
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. I ALSO
GOT IN. AS OSHA TEN FIRST AID.
FORKLIFTS AND CHAINSAWS TWELVE.
AMONG THE AMONG THE MANY OTHER
CIRCUIT THERE OFFERED YEAR. AND
THE GREAT THING ABOUT YOU SEE
THAT- I GOT PAID WHILE. YOU'RE
DOING ALL THESE TRAININGS AND
WHATNOT AND THEY ALSO OFFER.
MONEY. FOR MY CLASSES ADULTS AS
WELL. SO BEFORE I JOIN YOU SEE
I DIDN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT TO
DO- WITH MY LIFE. REWIS I
REALLY HAD NO EXPERIENCE
WHATSOEVER- BUT THANKS TO ALL
THE EXPERIENCE AND SKILLS THAT
I'VE LEARNED. CAN YOU SEE I'M
EXCITED TO SAY THAT I WILL BE
LEAVING HOUSTON JANUARY-
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN OFFERED A JOB
WORKING CONSTRUCTION. AND LIKE
I SAID IF I HADN'T JOINED YOU
SEE I DON'T KNOW WHERE I'D BE
BUT I'M HAPPY WITH ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY'VE
GIVEN ME- IT IT SHAPED ME. AS A
HUMAN BEING I WOULD SAY AS WELL
IT HELP ME OUT QUITE A LOT AND-
GAVE HELP ME COMPARE US TO
CONNECTS THAT IN LIGHT IT
BETTER MYSELF. SO I'M HOPING
THAT OTHERS LIKE ME WILL GET
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY. SB SIX OR
BOARD PASSED TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DESERVED
COMPLETO. I COULDN'T TELL IF
THAT WAS ONE TWO BROKEN INTO
TWO OR THAT WAS BOTH OF YOUR
LEAVE LEAVE US TO. OKAY PERFECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN WE
WILL MOVE TO OUR PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIX OH FOUR IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE.
ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN ROOM TWENTY. SAYING NO.
MONTEREY WE WILL GO TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX OH FOUR AND THIS IS JUST
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU AND THE GENERAL VIEW
IS TO ASK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT ARE
YOUR LINE NUMBER THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
THIS IS DANIELLE LYNCH
EXPRESSED COR ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
CALIFORNIA OFFICIALS YOUR LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION. AN
INSULAR REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND NATURE FOR ALL ON
THE COURT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
S. AND AS A REMINDER LAYS
GERMAN OF YOUR SUPPORT SB SIX
ZERO FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
PERSON I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WILL
MOVE TO- OPPOSITION AND SO IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THIS COMMITTEE
ROOM THAT WISHES TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL SIX
OH FOUR. ANYONE IT CAN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY. WHAT'S ON THE- NO
ONE THERE A MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYBODY QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO SENATE
BILL SIX OH FOUR. THANK YOU AND
ONE CAN MAYES GENERAL COULD YOU
WISH TO. DO IN OPPOSITION SB
SIX ZERO FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
PERSON I'VE KNOWN QUEUING UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE OR THEIR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FOR EVENTUALLY A
MOTION ON SENATE BILL SIX OH
FOUR. YEAH OUR MOVED BY JONES
IN A ROOF I WAS GOING TO NOTE
UNDER COMMENTS AT SOME POINT
THAT THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
TYPICAL WHY SO TO RASO JONES
FIFTH. BONTA OKAY SENATOR WAY
SO YOU CAN CLOSE OF THE HOUSES-
THAT IT'S A GOOD BILL. YOU PUT
A LOT OF WORK INTO THIS BILL
SOME GLAD THAT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION AND I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE. YOUR SUPPORT TO HELP A
TRAIN OR THE FUTURE WORKFORCE
OF CALIFORNIA. THAT'S CORRECT-
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
IF. FILE ITEM FOR SB SIX OLD
FOR THE MOTION DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AIRED HI. HI JONES. HOMES HI
ALLEN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN
GROVE GROVE HI HERTZBERG HUESO
HI HUESO ARE A LOAN. STERN. MON
STEPPED AWAY SENATOR MONIQUE
LIMON STEPPED AWAY AND I SAW
SENATOR STERN THERE FOR A
MOMENT BUT HE STEPPED AWAY SO
THAT HAS FIVE VOTES THAT'S
ENOUGH BUT WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL
AND- WE ARE FINANCED EARLIER
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GO OUT OF
ORDER TO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SB
SEVEN NINE NINE BY SENATOR
GLAZERS HE'S HERE JUST SO THOSE
OF YOU ARE ON THE PHONE JUST
KNOW THAT- TESTIMONY AND THE
WEIGHT SUPPORT AND THE WEED
OPPOSITION WILL BE COMING UP.
AFTER A SENATOR GLAZERS
PRESENTATION SO WE WILL MOVE TO
ITEM FOURTEEN SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINE NINE SENATOR GLAZERS
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
PROTECT THANK YOU CHAIR LAYERED
AND I WANT TO THANK TECH
COMMITTEE AND- MY COLLEAGUES
THROUGH DIFFERENCE AND LOG ME
TO PRESENT I STAND I WAS IN
LINE FOR MICHAEL WHICH SHOT AND
I GET MY SECOND ONE TODAY SO I
HAVE- WANNA MAKE SURE I CANNOT
MAKE THAT APPOINTMENT I
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP AND NO I
APPRECIATED I GOT MINE- RIGHT
AFTER AN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND WANTED EVERYBODY
TO BE QUIET AND MOVED THE
MEETING WHEN THAT WAS HAPPENING
SO. THANK OR SHARE YOUR
POSITION AS A PRESENT THIS BILL
LET ME JUST TAKE KNOWLEDGE THE
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS THAT WAS
PREPARED BY YOUR COMMITTEE
pHELD TALKS BOUT THE HISTORY
AND THE AT THE HISTORY OF THIS-
OF THE OF THE PROPERTY AS WELL
AS THE HISTORY OF THIS BILL IN
THE SENATE THE SENATE IS PUT
THIS BILL OUT AND SIMILAR FORM
ON AT LEAST TWO OTHER OCCASIONS
BUT WE'RE BACK AGAIN IT IS A
DISTRICT BILL FOR ME IN SOME
WAYS ALTHOUGH FOR THE BAY AREA
REGION IT'S A GREAT.
CONSERVATION BILL- THAT. WOULD
BENEFIT EVERYBODY IN OUR IN OUR
REGION. BASICALLY AS SIX SEVEN
NINE WITH. THAT OF AND REC
PRESERVE. THE ALAMEDA TO THE
EXPANSION FOR CONSERVATION
PURPOSES. IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
LANDSCAPE I THINK MY WITNESSES
WILL SPEAK TO THAT AT THE
MOMENT. THIS CONSERVATION WOULD
OCCUR ONLY IF AT LEAST ONLY IF
AT LEAST NINE MILLION DOLLARS
OR TRANSFERRED OR DONATED. TO
THE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE TRUST
FUND REIMBURSING THE FINE FOR
THE ORIGINAL COST OF THE LAND
AND- A HAT TIP TO CENTER. NOW
SENATOR EGGMAN. THEN CHAIR
EGGMAN AND HEARD THIS BILL IN
THE ASSEMBLY A FEW YEARS BACK
AND- INSISTED UPON THAT
REIMBURSEMENT BEING AT THAT
LEVEL AND IT IS INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL- THAT COMMITMENT
REMAINS. A BIT OF HISTORY IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A PLAN TO
XPAND THE CARNEGIE STATE
RECREATION AREA FOR RECREATION
WAS APPROVED. BUT IT LED TO A
BROAD AT. OPPOSITION INCLUDING
FROM THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA. AND
OTHER PUBLICATIONS HE'S IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR THE
SACRAMENTO SUPERIOR COURT RULED
IN FAVOR OF THE COUNTIES-
CRITICISM OF THE I. R. THAT WAS
DONE. THE COURT LAID OUT A
WHOLE HOST OF PLACES IN WHICH
THE E. R. WAS DEFICIENT. THIS
ACTION THAT MAKES THIS A GOOD
TIME FOR THE STATE TO
REEVALUATE THE PROJECT AND IN
MY VIEW MOVE IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION- AND IT AND RESOLVE
THIS TWENTY YEAR CONFLICT OVER
THE EXPANSION OF THIS OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE PARKED AT THAT
IS IN MY DISTRICT. IN ADDITION
THIS BILL IS IN UNISON WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
WOULD SET A GOAL FOR THE STATE
TO PROTECT 30% OF CALIFORNIA'S
LANDS AND WATERS. BY TWENTY
THIRTY INCLUDING PROTECTING
RESTORING BIODIVERSITY ENSURING
CONSERVATION MEASURES. THIS
MEASURE SUPPORTED BY A VARIETY
OF STAKEHOLDERS. AND WE'RE SOME
OF WHOM ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM
THE MOMENT I WOULD THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
GLAZERS. WE HAVE TO PEOPLE
LISTED AS LEAD SUPPORT TO
CONSIDER FOUR MINUTES AND
SUPPORT. BRANDON DAWSON FROM
THE SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA BETH
WORST BURE FROM CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY. THEY'RE
BOTH ON THE CO HOST CONFERENCE
LINE- MISTER. MISTER DAWSON IF
YOU'RE THERE YOU CAN GO FIRST
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS BURNING
DOCKING ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA- WITH MANY OTHERS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS TO PRESERVE JEFF
ARE GOING INTO THE LEGACY FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS- NETWORK
BURKE WILL SPEAK TO THE PROJECT
BACK STATUS ON A HIGHLIGHTS
MOTHER BACK WELL. I'M NOT
PRESERVATION OF JUST THE
PARKING THE TOPCON PRIORITY FOR
THE EAST BAY REGION THE
ENTIRETY OF TOUCH OUR LOOK AT
IN EASTERN ALEMANNIC. AND
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT PROPOSAL
PARK PROJECT. ONLY FROM
PROFESSORS AND TRYING. TO THE
LEADERS RANGERS AND CONSERVE
THE GROUPS. BUT I FROM OTHER
AGENCY SUCH AS THE ABOUT. CITY
WITH LIVERMORE. IF THEY
REGIONAL ARTIST AND OTHERS.
WHILE LOCATED ALAMEDA COUNTY
THE PARKING ALSO SERVE URBAN
YOU AND I. CENTRAL VALLEY.
BLOOD OFTEN POUNDS LODGED IS A
LOCAL. AND SB NINETY OF THE BIO
LOCAL MAN NEEDED TO IT AS A ACT
OF. ACCOUNTABLE BY. STATE PARK
YOU KNOW IT'S AND WE ARE. TO BE
PAID BY DOLLARS ARE NOT. FROM
THE RED SOMETIMES A PART OF.
YOUR MATCHES COUNTRY PRIORITIES.
ASTRONOMICAL DIMENSION I'M NOT
PRESERVATION TYPE OF. ON MY
WITH THE GOVERNOR THIRTY BY TWO
EXACTLY ORDERS WHICH IS A- LAST
FALL. THEY PROTECT BOTTOM.
PROVIDE CRIME CHANGE IS A-
COULD WHILE LIKE. OF AN
INCREASE IN THE OF NATURE.
BECAUSE PUBLIC SOME. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALAMEDA OF UP WITH
LOW FUNDS PAY THE TAX THREE.
YEARS ARE PARKING. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN LOOK AGENCY AND ALL ME
COUNTY OF DESIGNATED UNDER. ON
WILL ALSO LANDFILL OPENS FUNDED
STATE PARKS. NO WE CAN BE OUR A
CURRENTLY PROJECT AS PART. THE
LOCAL FUNDS TO BE USED TO PAY
THE STATE DEPARTMENT. EASEMENTS
WHICH THE LAN STATE LAND OR THE
TRANSFER OF TO A LOT COLLEGE OF
NGO AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
THE CARD UNDER EXTENT OF
KEARNEY AS WE ARE A AND HAVE
THE PART. AND LASTLY I JUST
WANT TO KNOW THAT SHOULD
CONTAIN THAT SHE NOT NINE SERVE
EVERYONE ALL IN SUPPORT OF A
THREE. CENTER BY DIVERSITY A
BUNCH CAL. IN THE NATURE. WE
ARE STREETS BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH IN AND NOW WILL
MOVE TO. A BETH WORST FROM CAL
NATIVE SIGN. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING I'M I'M HERE TO OTHER
FOR HERE TO ALLEN IT HAS SIX.
WE HASSLE. THE PLACE SPECIAL
THAT IT MADE DESCRIPTIONS MACAU
PUBLIC RESEARCH CODE BOTH AND
NOW AND CULTURAL. TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CONSENSUS HAS THAT
JUST AS AS RARE ECOLOGICAL
VALUE IN THE BOND OF HIGH
CENTER NATURAL. COULDN'T
THREATENED DANGER AND SPECIAL
STATUS. SENSITIVE HAVE AND
VEGETATE COMMUNITY RARE PLANTS
AND A CRITIC LINKAGE WHILE A
QUARTER SH NEWER RESEARCH AND
SHOWS THE NORTH DIABLO RANGE
INCLUDE TEST SHOULD BE A TOP
EIGHT CONSERVE PRAYER EACH THE
PLAY LIFE YOU RANKS. FOR AND
FOR HER THE SERVER. YOU HAVE
SHOWN THAT THE RECREATIONAL OHB
USE CAUSES IRREPARABLE DAMAGE
TO SOILS EDUCATION AND WHILE
LIKE. SENSITIVE NATURAL
RESOURCES DISTRIBUTED
THROUGHOUT ALMOST THE ENTIRE
EXPANSION AREA MAKING IT
IMPOSSIBLE BOTH TO PROTECT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND ALLOW
ALLEGE THE RECREATION THE
TESLA. AND MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS. WHO DOESN'T ALWAYS
EXPANSION. WE CAN'T IGNORE THE
SCIENCE AT THE MATH AND THAT.
TO FOLLOW AN OUTDATED PLAN WE
KNOW THAT- G. RECREATIONS
DISTRACTING WE KNOW THAT SOME
PLACES LIKE TEST OR SOMETHING
NOT SUITABLE FOR A WITCHING
RECREATION. AND ALWAYS BE PART
CAN DECIDED ELSEWHERE. CANNOT
BE REMOVED OR REPLACED. IS AN
EXAMPLE OR MODEL OF THE
BIOLOGICALLY IMPORTANT
CULTURALLY SIGNIFICANT. INTACT
A CONSISTENT. AT THE STATE HAS
A DUTY PRESERVE. PLEASE PROTECT
VOTE YES ON SEVEN SB SO NINETY
NINE IS WRITTEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU GUYS
WERE JUST WITHIN THE TIME
CONGRATULATIONS. WE WILL NOW
MOVES TO ANY TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION. AND
TO POSITION IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THIS HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN NINE NINE. ANYONE IN
ROOM. TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE
A MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINE THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYONE TO- JUST
GIVE THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. SEVEN NINE NINE. OKAY IN IN
SUPPORT OF SEVENTY NINE NINE
WE'LL GO TO LINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN
SUPPORT OF SEVENTY NINE NINE.
OKAY GO TO LINE FIFTY TWO. I
WANTED TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
WANTED TO DO YES. HELLO MANY
MYSTERE MACLEOD I AM- BOARD
MEMBER WITH CALIFORNIA OFF ROAD
VEHICLES SITUATION FOR MENTOR
CAL COUNTY CALIFORNIA I IN
STRONG OPPOSITION SENATE BILL
THIS IS THE SERVER WE WILL NOTE
THIS BUT THIS IS THE PERIOD FOR
PEOPLE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT WE
WILL NOTICE SO YOU'RE IN THE
RECORD BUT THIS WAS THE TIME TO
QUEUE UP IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL SEVEN NINE NINE
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. BERMAN
PLEASE M. REMINDER QUICK. IN
SUPPORT OF SEVEN B. SEVEN NINE
NINE. OUTLINED SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS DOUG HOUSTON
REPRESENTING EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICT WE WANT TO ALIGN
OUR POSITION OR COMMENTS WITH
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINE
NINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. ALEX'S
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS NINA ESCALANTE I'M
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE FOUNDATION AND ALAMEDA
CREEK ALLIANCE BOTH STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINE NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. AT LINE.
SIXTY FIVE. HI THIS IS TAMERA
ROYCE WITH FRIENDS OF OPEN
SPACE AND VINEYARDS AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
LINE FIFTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS
CHERYL LANDON I AM WITH CASTRO
VALLEY HUDDLE SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT- SB SEVEN NINE
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT COLON. LINE.
THIRTY SEVEN. BY THAT THE ONE
PUBLIC AUTOMATIC **** IN YOUR
LENDERS MANAGER FOR STATE MOUNT
DIABLO SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
LINE FIFTY FIVE. THIS IS JUDY
WILL SING I REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA- CASTRO VALLEY
HUDDLE AND SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT AGAINST THE
INCRIMINATING NINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT COLUMN.
NINE FIFTY SIX. HELLO MY
NAME'S- DICTIONARY- I'M
SPEAKING FOR THE ALTAMONT
LANDFILL OPEN SPACE COMMITTEE.
NEXT CALL. NINE FIFTY FOUR I
DIDN'T EVEN SAY. MY NAME IS. NO
POINT IN YOUR WALLET
REPRESENTING. REPRESENTING
STATEWIDE A CALIFORNIA NATIVE
GRASSLANDS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. IT'S
TARGETED OF AUDIO DELAY THEIR
MONTHLY. THE LINE AT. FIFTY
THREE. YES MY FIFTY THREE YEAR
OPEN. HELLO. YOU'RE WRONG
YOU'RE WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU GREG DOT. I REPRESENT
CARNEY YOU FOR EVER. I ALSO AM
A REPRESENTATIVE VOICES FOR
KIDS IN BOLINAS CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS OPENING UP TOP ROAD
SPACE I AM AN EXTREME STOCKS
STRONG OPPOSITION BUT WHAT YOU
ARE DOING I'M SORRY THIS IS
THIS IS THE- OF. SERVICES TO
POINT FOR SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WE WILL NOTE YOUR POSITION IN
OPPOSITION BUT THIS WAS JUST
NAME AND SUPPORT SO WILL NOT
OCCUR OPPOSITION MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. LINE SIXTY SIX. YES
HELLO WELL HELLO MORONIC GOOD
AFTERNOON HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER SPENCE I'M
REPRESENTING THE SOCIETY OF
AMERICAN INDIANS IN LIVERMORE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
BLUELINE. SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CELESTE
GERMANY AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING FRIENDS OF TESLA
PARK GREENBELT ALLIANCE
REGIONAL PARK ASSOCIATION. SAN
JOAQUIN AUDUBON SOCIETY IN THE
DELTA SIERRA GROUP OF THE
SIERRA CLUB IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF S. B. SEVEN NINE NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. LINE.
SEVENTY SIX. A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN DELFINO
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE STOCK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT COLON.
OKAY NO FURTHER RESPONSE TO
QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- NOW WE WILL MOVE
TO THE OPPOSITION AND THERE WAS
ONE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS A
DIANA MADE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
OFF ROAD VEHICLE ASSOCIATION-
MISS MADE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR GRANTING
ME TIME TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY. I
AM A CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR
GLAZERS. EACH OF YOU HAS
RECEIVED A CARNEGIE ASSESSMENT
THE DOCUMENT INCLUDES THE
HISTORY OF CARNEGIE STATE
VEHICULAR RECREATION AREA WITH
A FOCUS ON THE ALAMEDA TESLA
EXPANSION PARCEL. OVER TWENTY
YEARS AGO TWELVE MILLION ONLY
TREE TRUST FUND DOLLARS WERE
INVESTED FOR THE CARNEGIE SBRA
EXPANSION. TWELVE MILLION WAS
NOT A ONE AND DONE PAY OUT.
DURING THE LAST TWENTY THREE
YEARS STATE PARKS FIX THE SAN
FRANCISCO WATER DISTRICTS
MISTAKE COSTING ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION. MITIGATION CONTINUES
OF AN EARLY TWENTIETH CENTURY
MINING OPERATION.
ARCHAEOLOGICAL SITES A CATALOG
AND PROTECTED. FOR FUTURE
PROJECTS REQUIRE PUBLIC INPUT
STUDIES AND APPROVALS. B. O. H.
M. V. R. DIVISION OF STATE
PARKS HAS COMMITTED THE FUNDING
TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT WHILE
RESPONSIBLY DEVELOPING MULTIPLE
USERS ACCESS. YOU WAITED NORTH
OF CARNEGIE SCR A. R. LAWRENCE
STATES HUNDRED. AND A GUN RANGE
TO THE SOUTH ACCESS BIASED
MAINTAINED ROAD LOOK. IS STAN
WHICH IN. ALSO ACCESS BY THAT
IS A CAT RANCH. AND DELETE
HUNTING ENTERPRISE. THIS PARK
NEIGHBOR IT KNOWLEDGE IN
WRITING AT TIME OF PURCHASE SHE
SAID THE ACQUISITION OF THE
ALAMEDA CATHOLIC STILL WANTS TO
EXPAND- H. THE OPPORTUNITIES. A
COPY OF THIS DOCUMENT IS IN THE
REPORT FOR YOUR REFERENCE. THIS
IS IMPORTANT AS THIS NEIGHBOR'S
NAME IS ASSOCIATED WITH
LITIGATION AGAINST CARNEGIE S.
B. R. A. N. D. ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THERE
WILL BE PRESIDENT SACK WITH
THIS LEGISLATION. WE CALL THE
ESTATE OWNER WHO BLOCKED ACCESS
TO THE BEACH FRONTING ITS
PROPERTY. BEACH ACCESS IS STILL
IN LITIGATION APPROVAL OF THIS
BILL WILL SUPPORT HIS CLAIM THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHO CAN ACCESS
HIS BEACH. WEALTHY AND
POLITICALLY CONNECTED
INDIVIDUALS WILL FIGHT THIS
LEGISLATION TO ELIMINATE
UNDESIRABLE FROM THEIR PARK.
THIS IS LEGISLATIVE NIMBYISM. A
SECOND PRESIDENT IS MUCH MORE
WORRISOME BY STATUTE STANDARDS
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
EXCEED THOSE OF PARKS UNDER
FEDERAL STATE COUNTY OR CITY
MANAGEMENT. R. S. B. TWO FORTY
NINE ALL S. E. R. A.'S EXCEED
THESE ALREADY HIGH STANDARDS.
THIS LEGISLATION YOU SERVICE
PARKS DECISION MAKING A
DECISION MAKING AND MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY GOVERNOR NEWSOM MADE
THIS OBSERVATION IS TO TWENTY
NINETEEN VETO OF AB TEN EIGHTY
SIX. IT'S NOT ABOUT THE SCIENCE
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE FACTS ALL OF
THESE FACTORS ARE CHECKED IN
THE STATE PARKS COLUMN. IT IS
ABOUT DESPAIN DISDAIN FOR THOSE
WHO ENJOYING NATURE IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THAN OTHERS.
RECREATION SHOULD AND COULD BE
NONPARTISAN IF YOU ARE ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES CHOSE SIMPLY TO
SUPPORT OUR STATE PARK. BY THE
WAY THIS OFF ROADER IS A
DEMOCRAT. SENATOR GLAZERS. IN
ADDITION TO THE FISCAL
IRRESPONSIBILITY OF
TRANSFERRING NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM STATE COFFERS INTO
THE O. H. P. FUN TO DO WHAT IS
ALREADY BEING DONE THIS
PROPOSED LEGISLATION IS
DESIGNED FOR WEALTHY
POLITICALLY CONNECTED ENTITIES.
SEEK TO DENY ACCESS TO REGULAR
CITIZENS THEY DEEM UNWORTHY. IT
IS DELIBERATELY INTENDED TO
DEPRIVE CERTAIN CALIFORNIANS
ACCESS TO OUR STATE PARKS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW WE
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION JUST
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
AND WILL BEGIN WITH THIS
COMMITTEE ROLE MR ANYBODY IN
THIS COMMITTEE ROAMED WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. SEEING NONE WE WILL GO TO
A ROOM TWENTY FORTY. I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE- THIS WOULD BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY TO
SPEAK IN. OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. AND IT'S JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION AND
SO WE HAVE A MAXIMUM OF FIFTEEN
MINUTES IN CASE WE HAVE THAT
MANY CALLS. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY TWO. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
CAPULETS REPRESENTING THE OFF
ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION AND STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
THE LINE. TWENTY THREE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHANGE OF OUR
GENDER WE HAVE A BETA
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE THE
RIGHTS AND SAFETY ORGANIZATION
AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BLIND. EIGHTY
EIGHT ZERO. LINE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE RESPONSE
THEY'RE NOT RELYING ON
MODERATORS. BLIND. SEVENTY
NINE. YES I GOT DISCONNECTED I
AM SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF SEVEN
NINETY NINE THIS IS JEAN KING
AND I AM REPRESENTING DEAL ONLY
A LOT OF BEEN ASSOCIATION AND
ALSO FRIENDS OF WHAT THE MARCH
IN APPROVAL OF SEVEN NINETY
NINE PARDON ME HI THANK YOU
OKAY THIS IS FOR OPPOSITION WE
WILL NOTE THAT FOR THE RECORD
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
OPPOSITION LINE AIM
ORGANIZATION LINE POSITION. ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. OCT GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
NICHOLAS HARRIS WESTERN STATES
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE AMERICAN
MOTORCYCLIST ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT A CALL.
LINE FIFTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME
IS GERMAN CLOUD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA OFFERED VEHICLE SO
SHE XIN AND PROTECT THE WHICH
WE ACCESS- IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT KOHLER. THE LINE. SEVEN
ZERO. HI MY NAME IS KATIE
PROGRESS I AM A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT AT WORK HERE OF MY
REMARK AND STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. LINE. FIFTY THREE.
BY. FIFTY THREE. NO RESPONSE
ONE FIFTY THREE NO FURTHER
RESPONSE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF A MODERATOR WILL
BRING THE MATTER BACK BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE. MISTER JONES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MISTER GLAZIER AND- YOU MAY
HAVE COVERED THIS IN YOUR
OPENING ON HOLIDAYS IF YOU DID
THAT I MISSED IT BUT I'M
LOOKING AT THE GOVERNOR'S- BY
VETO MESSAGE. LAST YEAR AND-
I'LL JUST READ THE FINAL
PARAGRAPH THERE'S BEEN IT'S A
SHORT MESSAGE. THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS FAILED TO CONDUCT
SUFFICIENT STUDY OF THIS
PROPERTY OR IS MISMANAGING THIS
STATE RESOURCE THE PARK WAS
PURCHASED FOR THE BENEFIT OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND SHOULD
REMAIN A STATE PARK SO THAT
RAISES THE CONCERN OF YOU KNOW
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS
BILL FROM THE BILL LAST YEAR.
THROUGH THE CHAIR THANK YOU
CENTER VIOLENCE I THINK THAT IT
SHOWS A MISUNDERSTANDING ON THE
PART OF THE EXECUTIVE IS STILL
WHAT. WE'RE PROPOSING ARE
PROPOSING THAT IT BE A STATE
PARK THAT IT BE A PUBLIC. A
PRESERVATION AREA AND I THINK
THAT WAS INTO. CLEARLY
UNDERSTOOD IN REGARD TO- THAT
THE ACTIONS HE TOOK ON THE BILL.
WHAT IS WAS THAT- YEAH YEAH I
REMEMBER THAT BEING FOR THE
CONVERSATION LAST YEAR THAT IT.
IS WAS THAT A NEW REQUIREMENT
THAT IT GOES TO A NONPROFIT. I
THINK WHAT WE HAVE ADDED INTO
THIS BILL IS A- AN ACTUAL
PAYMENT. FOR CONSERVATION OF IT
SO THAT IT BE ALLOWED TO BE PUT
IN CONSERVATION- PURPOSES
THAT'S THAT'S IN THE BILL- AS A%
ELEMENT OF THE BILL PREVIOUSLY-
THE BILL I GAVE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT. OF PARKS AND REC
THE OPTION. OF- OF SELLING THE
PROPERTY AND DO A CLEARED UP
THIS BILL MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
THERE SHALL BE A SALE IF THESE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY ARE PROVIDED
AND IT WOULD GO INTO PERMANENT
PUBLIC PRESERVATION. ONE OF THE
CONCERNS I HAVE IS- I DIDN'T
GET A CHANCE TO LOOK UP THE
USAGE OF THE PARKER DID. FIND
THE MAP OF IT AND- AS A MATTER
OF FACT I I'M I'M DISAPPOINTED
A LITTLE BIT AYE. I DID A
MOTORCYCLE TOUR- IN DECEMBER AS
PART OF OUR SWEARING IN
CEREMONIES I RODE MY MOTORCYCLE
UP FROM SAN DIEGO THROUGH THE
MOUNTAINS AND THEN BACK TO THE
COAST. AND I JUST MISSED HI I
WAS ON VASKO ROAD AND FIVE
EIGHTY. AND IF I WOULD ON THIS
IS COMING BACK I WOULD JUST
DRIVE DOWN TO YOU KNOW COME SEE
THE PARK AND ENTER IT- YOU KNOW
I'VE GOT SOME AS WE ARE REYES
IN MY AREA. OF COURSE ON
CALIFORNIA'S GOT SOME FEDERAL
ONES AS WELL. AND I AND I KNOW
THAT THERE'S CONCERNS FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT- YOU KNOW THE
CONSERVATION AND ALL THAT.
WHICH IS IT IT'S A CONCERN
STATEWIDE YOU KNOW CONSERVATION
OF THE OF CALIFORNIA RESOURCES-
I JUST KIND OF I. YOU KNOW I
I'M LOOKING AT THE MAP AND IT
APPEARS TO BE KIND OF OUT IN
THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S EXACTLY CHIU AND
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE AS MUCH
RESIDENTIAL AREA OR INDUSTRIAL.
AREA AROUND THIS IS THAT
ACCURATE. WELL IT SAID IN THE
CITY OF LIVER. SO IT'S JUST
OUTSIDE THE YOU KNOW THE
TYPICAL. CITY CENTER OKAY.
URGENT MEASURES IT I WAS
READING THE MAP REYES BECAUSE
AT THIS AT THIS PROPERTY
BORDERS IN EXISTING- HV
PROPERTY THAT IS BEING USED
FOR- H. B. USE AND NOTHING IN
THIS BILL AFFECTS. THE EXISTING
L. H. B. USED F. AT THE
CARNEGIE SITE IT'S REALLY ONLY
ABOUT THE EXPANSION THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT STRICTLY MAKING
ABOUT CHANGING ANY OF THE-
ACTIVITIES I ON THAT WELL IT IS
GOOD THAT WE'RE NOT PROPOSING
BUILDING A MUCH HOUSES NEXT TO
IT SO THAT'S YOU KNOW. TEN TO
THE CURRENT USE OF THAT THAT'S
GOOD WELL THERE'S SOME CONCERNS
YOU KNOW US JANA. DUNES IS-
IT'S CLOSER BEING FOR. BIG I'M
SURE THERE'LL BE SOME. IN
LAWSUITS AROUND THAT YOU KNOW
THOSE IF THAT DOES STAY CLOSED
YOU KNOW THE FOLKS THAT ARE
USED TO USE KNOWS HOW TO DO IS
WE'RE GOING TO. YOU KNOW FIND A
NEW PLACE TO RECTORY- THIS IS
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS TO BE. AN
OFF ROAD PARK- BACK TO THE
CONSERVATION NO. YOU KNOW I
THINK ONE OF THE CROWN JEWELS
OF THE CALIFORNIA PARK SYSTEM
ARE THESE S. VRES- BECAUSE WE
FILE WE- YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN IN
THE OPERA COMMUNITY FOR A LONG
TIME AND I REMEMBER. YOU KNOW
THIRTY YEARS AGO WHEN A LOT OF
THESE WERE BEING PROPOSED THERE
WAS A LOT OF RESISTANCE FROM
THE OFF ROADERS BECAUSE- IT YOU
KNOW- THEY WERE BEING YOU KNOW
FOR LACK OF A BETTER TERM
CRAWLED INTO A SMALLER LOCATION
AND- THEY WERE REALLY CONCERNED
THAT. AND THE ENVIRONMENTALISTS
ARE CONCERNED THAT. WE WERE
GOING TO THE PLACES THAT WERE
BEING RESERVED FOR OFF ROAD USE
WE'RE GOING TO BE DESTROYED.
BECAUSE OF THE INTENSITY OF THE
USE. AND I THINK THAT WAS A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN AT THE TIME
BUT I THINK WE'VE PROVEN OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES. OF
THE OPERA COMMUNITY WORKING
TOGETHER WITH PARKS AND THE
CONSERVATION GROUPS. THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE TO. HAVE THIS OFF
HIGHWAY AND I'LL ADMIT INSTANCE
USE. BUT THE WAY THAT. THE YOU
THE PEOPLE USING THE PROPERTY
ARE WORKING WITH THE LAND
MANAGERS TO. MAINTAINING
CONTROL THE TRAILS AND PUT THEM
IN SPECIFIC AREAS AND AVOID.
THE NATIONAL RESOURCES AND ALSO
THE SPEAKER WHEN YOU'RE
SPEAKERS MENTIONED THE NATIVE
AMERICAN RESOURCES THAT ARE
PROTECTED- I THINK THEY'VE DONE
A GOOD JOB AND- I HAVEN'T BEEN
INTO YOUR AYE TOUR DR TEO- WELL
AS A COUPLE WEEKS AGO- BUT
OTHER THAN THAT I. HAVEN'T BEEN
IN ONE IN A WHILE SO I'M I'M
LOOKING FOR TO COME UP AND
DURING THIS ONE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL I. I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF PRESIDENT THAT
THE THAT THIS BILL THAT THIS.
IS A STATE PARK IT'S A STATE AS
WE ARE A AND THAT'S WHAT IT
SHOULD BE THANK YOU SIR. I'M
GOING TO. RECOGNIZE MYSELF TO
SPEAK TO THIS BILL. AND I'VE
HAD A LONG INVOLVEMENT WITH
THIS ISSUE. OF BOTH AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KNOWN FOR EIGHT
YEARS AS THE RESOURCES
SECRETARY WHICH HAD STATE PARKS
AND- AND THERE HAS BEEN AS
EITHER. SENATOR GLAZER SAID OR
THE- BUT NOW ALSO SAID THIS IS
BEEN GOING FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
I CAN REMEMBER AT LEAST TEN OR
TWELVE OF THEM. AND THERE BEEN
MANY PROPOSALS FROM SUCCESS OF
LEGISLATORS TO DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE. THIS IS THE FIRST ONE
THAT ACTUALLY SATISFACTORILY
ADDRESSES THE UNDERLYING
PROCEDURAL ISSUE WHICH IS SAID
IF THIS IS GOING TO BE
CONSERVED. AND A NON- H. FI
FASHION. THEN CASH HAS TO GO TO
BUY OUT THE PRO H. P. FUND TO
DO IT AND THE PREVIOUS BILLS.
DID NOT DO THAT DID NOT ADDRESS
THAT THEY WANT TO GIVE STATE
PARKS THE OPTION TO FLIP IT.
THEY WANTED ALL THESE DIFFERENT
THINGS THIS FOR THE FIRST TIME
ADDRESSES THE UNDERLYING
PROCEDURAL ISSUE. NOW ARE OF
COURSE THANK THAT. HAVING WHEN
I WAS RESOURCES SECRETARY BEEN
LOBBIED BY BOTH SIDES
EXTENSIVELY. I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR A PARK AND
LAND CONSERVATION AND I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. THE KEY
THING IS THAT SENATOR GLAZER
HAS DDRESSED THIS IN THE
CORRECT FASHION IF THIS ISSUE
IS GOING TO BE ADDRESSED TO
CONSERVE THE LAND AND SO- AND
THAT IS WHY IT'S DIFFERENT THAN
THE PREVIOUS ONES BECAUSE ALL
THE PREVIOUS ONES. WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO LEAD TO
THE CONSERVATION OF THE LAND
WITHOUT PAYING BACK THE O. H.
P. FONT THIS BILL ADDRESSES TO.
SO AND THEN IF THERE ARE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES THERE'S THE MONEY
THERE TO ADDRESS THE OF OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES SO. I'M GOING TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE. SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TO. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER KIND OR- IS THERE MOTION.
BY THE BILL WAS MOVED BY
SENATOR HOLLAND- EXCUSE ME LET
ME GIVE YOU A RIGHT TO CLOSE
THANK YOU CHAIR LAYERED IN THE
ME MENTION I HAVE A FAMILY
MEMBER THAT TO ENJOY THIS
ACTIVITY I ALSO HAVE MANY
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT AND
ENJOY THIS ACTIVITY AND THEY DO
SO RIGHT NOW AT THE CARNEGIE
SITE- AND THAT BASED ON STATE
PARKS DATA. SAID THE USE IS
GOING DOWN AT THAT SITE JUST
BUT IT'S A PLACE I'VE BEEN OUT
TO SEE IN A LOT OF MY TO MY
CONSTITUENCY ENJOYS IT AND THIS
BILL WILL HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH THAT EXISTING- ACTIVITY I
WOULD SAY THIS TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT- IF YOU'RE
IF YOU'RE SUPPORTIVE OF OFF
HIGHWAY THIS ISN'T THE BILL FOR
YOU BECAUSE THIS WILL GET THE
MONEY BACK AND WE'LL FIND THAT
CAN GO LOOK FOR PLACES THAT ARE
MORE CHEAPER BOLAND. AND I ARE
BETTER PLACES FOR THIS ACTIVITY
THINK ABOUT IT THAT TWENTY
NOTED THAT THE MONEY THAT'S
BEEN IT AT THAT TO ACQUIRE
THOSE THESE EXISTING PROPERTIES
ADJACENT PROPERTIES IT'S JUT
SAT THERE FOR TWENTY YEARS IT'S
BEEN A LITIGATION LITIGATION
LITIGATION. I DON'T THINK IT'S
EVER GOING TO CHANGE AND SO
THIS BILL GETS GETS MONEY BACK
INTO THAT FINE AND THEY CAN
LOOK FOR PLACES ELSEWHERE TO
OFFER THAT ACTIVITY GO WITH A
PLAN THAT WOULD BE- AS
ECOLOGICALLY SPECIAL IS THE
LAND THAT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE TODAY AND WITH THAT
I THINK THIS IS A WIN WIN BILL
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN S. B.
S. NINE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED HI. ALL
RIGHT JONES. JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN. GROVE
HERTZBERG. HUESO LOAN. STERN.
YOUR NINE AND SENATOR STERN
SINCE WE DIDN'T RECOGNIZE YOU
BEFORE WOULD YOU PLEASE TELL US
WHICH DISTRICT A PERSON IS WITH
COUNTY. DIRECTOR JEREMY WHAT'S-
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEBTS
OF RECOGNIZED STERN ON SO
THAT'S THREE ICE ONE NO WILL
PUT THE MEASURE ON CALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SURE
THANK YOU FOR THAT TO THE
GRACIOUSNESS ALLOWED ME TO SAFE
TRAVELS AND- THANK SHOT. WE'RE
EXCUSE ME. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE. SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTY SIX UNDER
STERN HE'S HERE TOO TO PRESENT
REMOTELY AND LET ME JUST SAY
THAT- WE ONLY. WE HAVE FOUR
BILLS AFTER THIS AND- SENATOR
CAP A YEAR- YOU'RE GOING TO BE
NEXT UP AFTER SENATOR STERN
PRESENTS THIS BILL SENATOR
STERN- WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUNG ONES
WORK KEEPING OUR AD ORDER
BUSINESS MOVING- AND GETTING
THROUGH ALL THESE IMPORTANT
BILLS TODAY- SB THREE SEVENTY
SIX IS. A RE VISITATION OF AN
ISSUE- THE BILL THAT DIED- THAT
NOT EVEN THE ELEVENTH HOUR BUT
THE ELEVENTH AND A HALF HOUR OF
SESSION. LAST YEAR BUT WE'VE
REALLY REFINED OUR APPROACH
LAST YEAR WE WERE WE WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY CONCERNED ABOUT-
THE RISKS IN WILDLIFE
TRAFFICKING- BOTH IN LIVE
ANIMALS AS WELL AS IN TROPHIES
IN ANIMAL PARTS- NOT JUST FOR-
SOME OF THE BLACK MARKET
ACTIVITY IS GOING ON OUT THERE
BUT MOSTLY ABOUT THE RISK IS
NOT A DISEASE. SPREAD IN LIGHT
OF SOME OF THE FINDINGS WE'VE
DISCOVERED FOR COVIDIEN- PAST.
FLUS IN OTHER MAJOR PANDEMICS
WE'VE SEEN ORIGINATING FROM DO
NOT ASK ORIGINS- THE BILL THIS
YEAR- IS REFINED IT SEATS IT
SQUARELY FOCUSED ON THAT ISSUE
THE BILL IS NO LONGER- TOUCHING
ON ON SOME OF THE- ISSUES
AROUND TROPHIES IMPORTATION OF
TROPHIES OR ANIMAL PARTS. ARE
AT THIS POINT WE THINK THE NEW
MINISTRATION THAT IS IN
POSITION TO HANDLE SOME OF
THOSE BROADER. CONSERVATION IN
IMPORTATION CONCERNS- BUT THE
BILL HERE TODAY IS SQUARELY
FOCUSED ON- THE MOVEMENT
TRAFFICKING IMPORTATION TRADE
OF LIVE ANIMALS IN CALIFORNIA
IN VARIOUS KINDS OF MARKET
PLACES- AND WE THINK THAT. THIS
MEASURE IS CRITICAL TO
PREVENTING- THE NEXT PANDEMIC-
THAT THAT THESE KIND OF
PREVENTATIVE WORK HAVING A
COORDINATED ENFORCEMENT ABILITY
NOT JUST WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE BUT-
HOPEFULLY ACROSS THE COUNTRY ON
INTERSTATE AND A FEDERAL BASIS
WILL PREVENT US. FROM HAVING
GAPS IN OUR SYSTEM WHERE YOU
HAVE CITY ONE CDS RANGER. YOU
KNOW IT ENTIRE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH TO TRACK
SOME OF THIS STUFF OR RELYING
SIMPLY ON PAPER DATA BUT NOT
HAVING ENOUGH BOOTS ON THE
GROUND TO MAKE SURE THAT- WERE
ABLE TO STOP- BLACK MARKET
ACTIVITY THAT COULD POSE A RISK
TO HEALTH AND SAFETY. AS WELL
AS STATES BIODIVERSITY- HOWEVER
I DO WANT TO BE CLEAR- WE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING TO SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNED WITH THIS BILL THAT
THINK IT'S IT MAY BE A PROXY
FOR- REACHING INTO THE
ACTIVITIES OF. ZOOS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BOTH ACA OR
CA ZOOS- AND SOMEHOW TRYING TO.
SHUT THEM DOWN OR CHANGE THEIR
ACTIVITIES AND I WANT TO
CLARIFY FOR THE RECORD AND I
KNOW WE'VE DONE THIS PRIVATELY
BUT STATE PUBLICLY THAT IS
REALLY NOT THE INTENTION OF
THIS LEGISLATION. WE ARE
LOOKING IN VERY NARROW IN
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
CDFW- WOULD PRO ACTIVELY
SUSPEND THE ABILITY TO IMPORT.
OR SELL OR TRADE CERTAIN
ANIMALS IF AND ONLY IF. THERE
IS SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE IN A
WRITTEN FINDING THAT SUGGESTS
YOU NOT A TRANSMISSION FROM
THAT SPECIES OR A CLOSELY
RELATED SPECIES WITHIN THE SAME
FAMILIES. COULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR A NOVEL AND NOT PREVIOUSLY
REPORTED READILY TRANSMISSIBLE
DISEASE- WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT- THERE THERE'S A DESIRE
FOR A BIT MORE CLARITY ABOUT
HOW CDFW WOULD ADMINISTER SUCH
A STANDARD. WHETHER THEY BE
REINVENTING THE WHOLE NEW
PROCESS OR RELYING ON SOME OF
THEIR EXISTING- PROCESS SEES
AND I WANT TO COMMIT UP FRONT
TO WORKING THROUGH SOME OF
THOSE ENFORCEMENT DETAILS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH THIS BILL KNOW
EXACTLY. WHAT THEY'RE GETTING-
AND A LOT OF HIS WORK THAT THE
MAINSTREAM EITHER PRIVATE OR
PUBLIC ZOOS ARE. ALREADY DOING-
SO I. THAT CLEARED HELPS GO FOR
AND I WITH ME TODAY TO TOO-
TESTED. IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE WE HAVE NICHOLAS
SACKETT I WAS SOCIAL COMPASSION
IN LEGISLATION AS WELL AS BRING
INCOMING- FOR CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
BOOK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
WAS JUST INTRODUCED WE HAVE. TO
READ SUPPORT WITNESSES THAT CAN-
SHARE FOR UP TO FOUR MINUTES
BETWEEN THEM THE FIRST ONE IS
NICHOLAS SOCKET AND THEN JUDY
MIGHT CAUSE SO MR SECOND
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU CHAIR I AND I AM A READING
THE STATEMENTS OF BURNING
COMING FROM THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. THE
INTERNATIONAL WILDLIFE TRADE IN
ADDITION TO BEING ONE OF THE
PRIMARY DRIVERS OF THE
EXTINCTION CRISIS WITH THE
LIKELY ORIGIN OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AS CONFIRMED
BY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION EARLIER THIS MONTH
BECAUSE OF THE NINETEEN LIKELY
ORIGINATED IN A BAT MADE THE
JUMP TO ANOTHER SPECIES AND
FROM THERE TO HUMANS. THIS
TRANSMISSION CHAIN LIKELY
OCCURRED IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
TRADING EITHER WILD CAUGHT OR
FARMED WILDLIFE. AND THE FIRST
LARGE OUTBREAK OF THE DISEASE
WAS ASSOCIATED WITH A LIVE
ANIMAL MARKETS GLOBALLY ABOUT
60% OF THE INFECTIOUS DISEASES
ARE CONSIDERED SYNODIC MEANING
THEY JUMPED FROM OTHER ANIMALS
TO PEOPLE AND MORE THAN 70% OF
THE UNITED TO DO THIS.
ORIGINATE WITH WILDLIFE.
SCIENTISTS BELIEVE THAT THE
MAJORITY OF ALL FUTURE EMERGING
INFECTIOUS DISEASES WILL COME
FROM WILDLIFE. THE COSBY
NINETEEN OUTBREAK HAS LED
NUMEROUS INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING
ELEMENTS OF THE U. N. AND THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION TO
CALL FOR BANS OR RESTRICTIONS
ON THE LIVE WILDLIFE TRADE. AND
LOCAL WOULD ARRIVE HERE VIA
HUMAN TRANSMISSION THE VIRUS
HAS REPEATEDLY JUMPED BETWEEN
PEOPLE AND CAPTIVE WILDLIFE.
THIS HAS OCCURRED AND MEAN
FARMS IN OREGON SUCH HUMAN
ANIMAL TRANSMISSION EVEN
THREATENED BOTH PEOPLE AND
WILDLIFE AND COULD LEAD TO THE
OUTBREAK OF NEW AND POTENTIALLY
MORE DANGEROUS VARIANTS OF THE
DISEASE. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
PRODUCE EXOTIC DISEASE RISK
REQUIRE THAT AN IMPORTER OR
SELLER OF WILDLIFE MUST FIRST
DEMONSTRATE THAT A POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS LIVE ANIMAL. IS NOT A
DISEASE OR IF THE PEOPLE. OR
OUR NATIVE WILDLIFE BEFORE CAN
COME INTO OR BE SOLD IN THE
STATE THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
THE NECESSARY APPROACH WE ORDER
PASSAGE OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ENRICHMENT.
CRUSOE WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
HI I'M JUDY MAN CREWS FOUNDER
AND PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION CO
SPONSORED THE BILL. I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS SOME INACCURACIES ABOUT
WHAT SB THREE SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOESN'T DO YOU WILL
HEAR THAT THE BILL UNFAIRLY
TREATED. DIFFERENTLY BASED ON
WHETHER THEY ARE ACCREDITED BY
AZ A ARE THE COMPETING B. A. A.
IT DOES NOT EXISTING ON
CALIFORNIA. AND IN OTHER STATES
AND THE FEDERAL LEVEL ALREADY
EXAM ACA ACCREDITED ZOOS FROM
CERTAIN PERMIT REQUIREMENTS.
THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THAT
NEWS LIKE THE ONE YOU WILL HEAR
FROM THAT CHOOSE NOT TO MEET
THE HIRE A VA STANDARDS. HAVE
LATCHED ON TO THIS BILL IN AN
EFFORT TO LOWER CALIFORNIA'S
STANDARDS. WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THIS IS APPROPRIATE BUT IN ANY
CASE THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL
IS ABOUT. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE A BLANKET PROHIBITION ON
IMPORTATION OF RESTRICTED
SPECIES ARE EVEN KNOWS SPECIES
THAT POSTED THE THREAT. WHERE
THERE ARE BROKER TO CALLS FOR
ROBUST HAS SEEN AFFECTED
TREATMENT ARE QUARANTINE THE
DEPARTMENT MAY ALLOW PERMITS
EVEN. TO NON AGA. THE VILLAGE
PRUDENT MEASURED RESPONSE TO
PUT HELLO PORTER AND DO NOT A
DISEASE. AND ARE WILD FROM IN
SPECIES. WE HOPE THAT PAST YEAR
HASDONE. THE VALUE AND AN
OUNCE OF PREVENTION WHEN
PROTECTING OURSELVES FROM DO
NOT EXPEL- BURKE WE DID NOT ASK
OUR OVER TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS
AND HUNDREDS OF INDIVIDUAL
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL. EIGHT
TWO RESPECT THE COMMITTEES
CAUGHT OFF. THEIR SUPPORT IS
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS. WE
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
YOU MIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW HERE'S THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO ADDRESS. THEIR
SUPPORT WITH THEIR NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WISHES TO DO THAT FOR
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY SIX.
SAYING NO ONE WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO ONE OUR
MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR S. B.
THREE SEVENTY SIX AND IT'S
JUST. NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE SEVEN SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PHOTO LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SEE CHALLENGES NOT
ROBINSON WE SHUDDER IN
TRADITIONAL LEVINE OF HALF OF
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT TO A
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
KIM JEFF FROM RESIDENTS OF LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HELLO CRISTINA
CURRENTS FOR ANIMAL DEFENDERS
INTERNATIONAL I'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO THE COURTROOM
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS AND
PANDEMIC STOP EARTH. JANET
PRESERVATION SOCIETY NATIONAL
PARK RESCUE PARTNERS AN ANIMAL
PROTECTION AND CONSERVATION IN
THE LIBERIAN TUNICA IMPENDING
RESCUE AND PROTECTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND ONCE AGAIN
MAYES GENERAL JEWISH SOCIAL
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE SEVEN SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MR PERSON AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NOBODY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BURKE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE ONE
WAIT OPPOSITION WITNESS CHARLIE
SAM IT FROM THOSE WHO A LOGICAL
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA AND THE
MONTEREY ZOO A LOGICAL SOCIETY
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CHARLIE SENATE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MY RESUME AND HE A.
AS CURRENTLY AUTHORED. SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX WILL HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON A SELECT
GROUP OF SEROLOGICAL PROPERTIES
AND ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVICE.
CURRENT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
WILL NO DOUBT BE USED TO SHUT
DOWN THE IMPORTANT. IMPORTATION
OF THE VITAL ANIMALS NECESSARY.
QUICK AND EASY TO SURVIVE IN
THIS NEW INDUSTRY. OUR THREE
MAIN CONCERNS START WITH
REDUNDANCY CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND THE VETERINARY PUBLIC
HEALTH SECTION OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC HEALTH ALREADY HAVE
ANIMALS. AND THE PROTOCOL. THAT
THEY PREVENT BLUES FROM
BRINGING IN WITHOUT DOING
SPECIFIC TESTING. WE ARE READY
TO HEAR TO THAT. NEXT WE WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE EXEMPTIONS
FOR ALL OF THIS IS A THIS
AMENDED LANGUAGE CURRENTLY ALL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE HELL TO
RESTRICTIONS REGARDING THE
IMPORT OF DETRIMENTAL SPECIES.
IF THIS BILL. IS TO ADDRESS THE
OBVIOUS NEW AND UNPRECEDENTED
CONCERN FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY THREAT WE CONTINUE TO
ASK WHY ANY ORGANISATION
IMPORTING ANIMALS IN THE STATE
WOULD BE EXEMPT. YES EXISTING
LAWS DO CURRENTLY EXEMPT ONE
YOU'LL HAVE TO CALL TRADE
ORGANIZATION FROM CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF CURRENT REGULATIONS.
BUT NOT FOR MATTERS HAVING TO
DO WITH PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY CONCERNS. HENCE THE
EXISTING DETRIMENTAL SPECIES
LANGUAGE. WE'VE RAISED A
QUESTION REGARDING WHAT LIST
THE ANIMALS DESCRIBED IN THIS
LOOKS LEGISLATION WILL BE
PLACED ON AND THAT QUESTION HAS
YET TO BE ANSWERED. IF THEY'RE
ON AN EXISTING DETRIMENTAL
SPECIES LIST. ALL WILL HAVE TO
ABIDE BY THE RESTRICTIONS AS
PROBABLY SHOULD BE. IF THEY'RE
PLACED ON A NEW LIST THEN ONE
ZERO LOGICAL TRADE ORGANIZATION
IS EXEMPT FROM THE
PROTECTIONIST LEGISLATION
CLAIMS TO OFFER CALIFORNIANS.
IT WOULD PROTECT CERTAIN JEWS
FROM WHAT THREATENS ALL THE
OTHER ISSUES IN THIS BILL EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S- A SCIENTIFIC
PROOF THAT COLBERT SPREAD FROM
HUMAN TO ANIMAL IS NOT
PREVENTABLE BY ANY IS A LOGICAL
ORGANIZATION. THIS MORNING I
TRIED TO GET ALL OF YOU A
DOCUMENT SUPPORTING THE CDC AND
THE USDA RECOMMENDED
RECOMMENDED CAPTIVE WILDLIFE
GUIDANCE PROTOCOLS THAT WAS
RELEASED THIS MORNING. THEY DO
NOT EXEMPT ANY IS- A CURRENT
FEDERAL BILL MOVING THROUGH
CONGRESS TODAY HR ONE FIFTY ONE
WITH NINETY TWO CO SPONSORS
TWENTY FROM CALIFORNIA. AND
SUPPORTED BY BOTH THE D. A. N.
A. Z. A. CLEARLY AIMED AT THE
STOPPING OF THIS DISEASE BEFORE
THEY ENTER THE COUNTRY AND
AGAIN OFFERS NO EXEMPTION FOR
EITHER ORGANIZATION. THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE RELATIVE TO SCIENCE
THAT ALLOWS FOR ANYONE TO
RECEIVE AN EXEMPTION FROM KOBE
PROTOCOLS AND INTRUDES. THERE'S
AN OBVIOUS IN SCIENTIFIC PROOF
OF THE OPPOSITE. IN THIS
CHAPTER IN THIS LAW WAS WRITTEN.
THERE WAS AN EXEMPTION GIVEN TO
ONE OF TRADE ORGANIZATION
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE ONLY ONE
THAT EXISTED. NOW THERE'S AN
ALTERNATIVE TRADE ORGANIZATION
CONTRARY TO PREVIOUS
TESTIMONIES USE THAT USED TO BE
A OVER AGA DO NOT DO SO TO
ESCAPE PROPER PROTOCOLS FOR OUR
ANIMALS. WHEN WRAPPING UP. WE
CONTINUE TO ASK SENATORS DURING
TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT A
NEW AND ESTABLISHED TRADE
ORGANIZATION. IS IN EXISTENCE
BUT WASN'T A FACTOR WHEN THE
OTHER TRADE ORGANIZATION WAS
PROVIDED IT'S EXEMPTION BECAUSE
OF ITS HIGHER STANDARDS THAN
THE STATE. C. A. A.'S STANDARDS
CLEARLY DO THE EXACT SAME THING
THEY EXCEED THE MINIMUM
STANDARDS OF THE STATE. OUR
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS- YOU'RE
YOU'RE AT FOUR MINUTES WILL
COULD YOU PLEASE WRAP UP OKAY.
YES SIR OUR REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS WILL PROTECT THE SIX
ISSUES OF THE TWENTY NINE
ACCREDITED ZOOS IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- NOW WE WILL MOVE TO. OUR
OPPOSITION- BOTH NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE HEARING
ROOM HERE THAT WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL.
THREE SEVENTY SIX. SAYING NO
ONE IS THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES THIS IS US SENATE BILL
THREE SEVENTY SIX THIS IS A
CHANCE FOR. PEOPLE TO JUST SAY
THEIR NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION
AND THEIR POSITION. IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
PERSON IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE.
ACOUSTIC MUSIC PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND YOU KNOW AT THIS TIME THREE
SEVENTY SIX LEGAL ONE. AWESOME
MY APOLOGIES THREE SEVENTY SIX
WHEN YOUR LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE TEACHERS WE
HAVE NO FORMALIZED POSITION BUT
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE WAY THE
BILL. MAY INADVERTENTLY IMPACT
THE FILM INDUSTRY WHERE WE
REPRESENT CONSTRAINED MORE
TRAINERS. OR WORKING WITH
DOCTOR AND STAFF- AND HOPE TO
GET THE BILL IN A BETTER PLACE
HEADING INTO THAT THE NEXT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. NEXTDOOR LINE NUMBER
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MICHELLE DURANT I
REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED WILD MIND AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
EXPLORE LINE NUMBER NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI YES MY NAME
IS MOLLY AND I'M ALSO CALLING
ON BEHALF OF WILD LANDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NOW THE LINE NUMBER
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHILE THAT HOLLYWOOD ANIMALS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR
CALLING FROM THE JUNGLE-
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. YES NEXT
TO A LINE NUMBER NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THAT A WILD. ANIMAL TRAINER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND ONCE
AGAIN LAYS JENNIFER YOUR IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE FOR YOUR NEXT
PARTY. YOU JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. JUST ANOTHER MOMENT.
THREE TO GO TO LINE NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HI MY NAME IS DALE ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF THE PROJECT
SURVIVAL OF CALIFORNIA LICENSE
RESTRICTED SPECIES OLDER CENTER
TWENTY FIVE STAFF HERE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSES OPPOSITION. IT
SUPPORT- YOU OPPOSE THE BILL
BUT TO SUPPORT THE OPOSITION
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
THE MODERATOR NEXT ARTICLE.
NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
NAME ON COLMAR FROM ONE MILLER
AN ALTERNATOR I'M A TRAINER.
POST OPPOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CALL MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NEXOBRID LINE
NUMBER ONE A ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RENEE
CON I AM AN EDUCATOR AT WILD
MIND THAT I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. AND AT
THIS TIME I HAVE NO FURTHER IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
BRING THE MATTER BACK BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE- MISTER JONES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MR STERN
ONE OF THE INTERESTING THINGS
AT. I GUESS THE POSITIVE
SERENDIPITOUS THINGS THAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR WITH LAST
YEAR'S BILL IS. LIES HOW MANY
ANIMAL SANCTUARIES I HAD IN MY
DISTRICT I MEAN YOU KNOW I'M
FROM SAN DIEGO AT THE WORLD
FAMOUS SAN DIEGO ZOO IN THE-
WORLD FAMOUS SENDING A WILD
ANIMAL PARK WHICH THEY CALL
SAFARI PARK NOW BUT I LIVE IN
SENDING A LONG ENOUGH TO KEEP
CALM AT THE WILD ANIMAL PARK-
AND- WELL I WAS LOOKING FORWARD
TO LAST YEAR BEING ABLE TO SET
UP. A TOURISM. AND I THINK IT
WAS HALF A DOZEN- OF. THEM
PLACES IN MY DISTRICT THAT- MR
STERN FOUND FOR ME SO I WAS
THANKFUL FOR THAT INCLUDING A
CAMEL DAIRY WHICH PEOPLE DON'T
BELIEVE ME THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY CAMEL DAIRY- BUT
THAT'S NOT FOR DRINKING IT SO
THEY MAKE A HEALTH CARE
PRODUCTS OUT OF THE- THE MILK-
THAT THE COWS. GIVE THEM- THAT
THE CAMEL CAL'S GIVE THEM SO- I
ALSO WANT TO THANK MR STERN HE
WAS ON THE PHONE WITH ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS LAST WEEK FOR- A
GRACIOUS PERIOD OF TIME. I'M
GONNA LAY OFF THE BILL TODAY-
IN HOPES THAT WE CAN FIND-
COMMON GROUND ON WHERE TO MOVE
FORWARD SO THAT TO MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE PROTECTED. BUT
I DID WANT TO PUBLICLY
RECOGNIZE IT HE WAS VERY
GRACIOUS WITH THEM AND. AND WE
HAD A VERY POSITIVE DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CENTER
GROVE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN AYE
MINUTE M. ECHO MY COLLEAGUES'
COMMENTS M. AS THEIR THAN NOT
SAN DIEGO BIT AT BAKERSFIELD
HAS ONLY ONCE YOU. IT'S A SMALL
CHINESE YOU CALLED COM THEY
TAKE IN M. ANIMAL RESCUES AND
ALSO ANIMALS THAT ARE BROUGHT
IN. AND THAT THEY ARE ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND SO AND
THEY'RE PRETTY BUSY WITH Z.
EIGHT GROUP. AND WE TALKED
ABOUT IT A LITTLE BIT AND THAT
YESTERDAY AND SO I HOPE YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE- ALTHOUGH IT'S A
VERY VERY SMALL THIS LITTLE
ZERO IN OUR COMMUNITY DOES
BRING A LOT OF PRIDE TO OUR
DISTRICT AND THEN. IT HAS
AMAZING EVENTS OUT THERE PRIOR
TO THE NINETEEN AND HOPEFULLY
SOON AND THEM. A LOT OF KIDS A
LOT OF AT RISK KIDS A LOT OF
SECOND SHE ANSWERS A LOT OF THE
COMMUNITY GOES OUT AND DOES
IT'S COMMON A CONTINUOUS BASIS
INCLUDING. AND SCHOOLS THAT
TAKE FIELD TRIPS OUT THERE SO.
I'M HOPING THIS BILL WON'T TO
STOP THEM FROM OPERATING. THANK
YOU- CENTER GROVE AND THEN. ARE
FOUND. BY PROCESS OF
ELIMINATION I WILL SAY A FEW
WORDS IT AND I WOULD JUST SAY
IT WAS A CONSTITUENT OF MINE
THAT WAS TO LEAD A PERCENT TURN
OPPOSITION AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY TO SENATOR STERN. I AM
GOING TO IN A MOMENT MOVED THE
BILL AND VOTE FOR BUT I THINK
THERE'S TWO ISSUES HERE FOR THE
FIRST ISSUE IS DESERVES A
DISAGREEMENT ON THE UNDERLYING
FACTS NOT EVEN A DISAGREEMENT
ON POLICY THERE STILL SOME
DISAGREEMENT SIGNIFICANTLY ON
THE UNDERLYING FACTS OF THE
SITUATION. AND I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS THOSE
AND SEE IF WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION BASED ON AN
AGREEMENT ON THE FACTS AND THEN
GET AT THE DISAGREEMENTS AND I
THINK THERE IS A LOT OF WORK TO
DO ON THIS BILL SO ARE WILL
MOVE THE BILL. AND I WILL
RECOGNIZE. US SENATOR STERN TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THANK YOU- TO BOTH SENATOR
GROVE AND JONES FOR THEIR-
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND I LIKE THEM-
HAVE MANY IMPORTANT SANCTUARY'S
WILDLIFE RESCUE CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICT FOR
GIVEN REST EVERYTHING FROM
GIVEN RESCUED TWO SEALS- TWO
BIRD SANCTUARIES- AND THESE ARE
REALLY CRUCIAL BACKBONE
INSTITUTIONS THAT I I'D SHARE.
THAT PRIDE IN- SO AS I
MENTIONED THE OUTSET THE INTENT
IS NOT TO. SHUT DOWN- THOSE
SANCTUARIES OR EVEN TO REACH
INTO THIS- UNDERLYING DISPUTE
ABOUT COMPETING ACCREDITATION
STANDARDS WHICH I HEARD YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD A LITTLE BIT THERE
ABOUT THE AZ EIGHT VERSES THE
Z. EIGHT AND THE WAIVERS THAT
ACA IS ABLE TO GET BUT NOT CA
RIGHT NOW THROUGH CDFW- SOME OF-THOSE UNDERLYING EXIT ISSUES
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHAT PRIVATE TEAMS ARE ALLOWED
TO DO AND WHAT YOU KNOW THESE.
AND THESE OTHER YES REPUBLIC
ZOOS ARE ALLOWED TO DO- WE'RE
TRYING NOT TO LITIGATE THOSE
ISSUES HERE WE REALIZE THERE
ARE SOME TENSIONS AND TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS POPPING UP WE
REALLY WANT TO STAY NARROWLY
FOCUSED ON THERE'S UNITED
DISEASE RISK ISSUE AND TO THAT
POINT I JUST WANTED FOR THE FOR
YOUR PURPOSES OF SETTING THE
RECORD STRAIGHT ON THE
EXEMPTION. THAT WAS- DISCUSSED
BY THE LEAD OPPOSITION WE WENT
THROUGH A PRETTY EXTENSIVELY ON
ONE OF OUR CALLS BEEN TRYING TO
DO AS MANY CALLS AS NECESSARY
AND REALLY DOING IN HERE BUT
THE V. TO BE CLEAR IF YOU ALL
WANT TO GO INTO THE TEXAS ME
FOR A QICK SECOND- THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE TO SECTION. TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THE FISH AND GAME CODE. I
IT'S ON- I DON'T KNOW. MAYBE
THE SIX EIGHT PAGE OF YOUR OF
THE- IN PRINT YOU GO DOWN TO
PAY. NINE SO TWENTY ONE FIFTY
HE- IS AN AMENDMENT THAT WAS
MADE BY- WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE OVER THE ASSEMBLY LAST
YEAR THAT WE'VE RETAINED HERE
BUT THE SOUL- EXEMPTION THERE
IS ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS FOR
A UNIVERSITY COLLEGE GOVERNMENT
RESEARCH AGENCY OR OTHER
BONAFIDE SCIENTIFIC INSTITUTION
CONDUCTING BONAFIDE MEDICAL OR
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH- WHAT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR THAT
EXEMPTION IS- YOU SPECIFIC. SIX
OR SEVEN INSTITUTIONS LIKE UCSF
UC RIVERSIDE I THINK STANFORD
HAS AN INSTITUTION WHERE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING DO NOT A
DISEASE RESEARCH ON SPECIFIC
ANIMALS IN THOSE LABS LIKE
SQUARELY LOOKING AT
EPIDEMIOLOGY RISK DOING
ANALYSIS THERE WE DON'T WANT TO
GET IN THE WAY THAT BONAFIDE
MEDICAL RESEARCH BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT. EITHER YOU KNOW BIG SAN
DIEGO ZOO ISRAEL IS DOING OR
YOU KNOW A SMALL ZOO LIKE
MONTEREY IS DOING NEITHER ONE
OF THOSE WOULD FIT INTO THAT
CATEGORY- THAT'S REALLY NOT THE
INTENTION THERE NOT EVEN
TEACHING ZOOS OR OTHER
EDUCATIONAL KIND OF ZOOS YOU
HAVE TO DO SPECIFICALLY.
BONAFIDE MEDICAL RESEARCH THAT
REQUIRES A LOT OF FEDERAL
PERMITTING AND IT'S VERY HIGH
RISK STUFF WITH YOU AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE IF YOU TRY TO BRING IN
BACKS THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
HAVE THIS VIRUS IN THEM TO
STUDY- THERE'S A WHOLE HOST OF
PROTOCOL SO WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO MAKE SPACE FOR THAT SPECIFIC
RESEARCH WHICH- ACTUALLY
FURTHERS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL WHICH IS. TO REDUCING
ARCTIC DISEASE RISK. AS TO
THOSE SORT OF OVERLYING ISSUES
OF THE TENSIONS BETWEEN- J.
EASY A- WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
NOT SETTLE ALL THAT HERE- AND-
BUT- WHAT I WILL COMMIT TO YOU
IT IS WORKING TO GET VERY CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF FACTS AND
HOPEFULLY GET ON THE SAME PAGE
EVEN WITH THE OPPOSITION ABOUT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND DOESN'T
DO SO THAT THE NEXT TIME. YOU
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE ON IT YOU FEEL- SQUARELY-
FUHRMAN ON YOUR FOOTING IT FOR
THE VOTE- BUT I THINK THAT THE
FACTS CARE THEMSELVES OUT IN
THE SECTION I JUST ARTICULATED-
AS WELL AS- SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY GIVEN HERE TODAY SO I
WOULD SINCERELY APPRECIATE YOUR
AYE VOTE AND I WANTED YOU TO
KNOW WITH THAT VOTE- COMES MY
ON GOING COMMITMENT. DO YOU
REALLY DO IN AND THE OP- DURING
THE TEAM COMES. TRYING SETTLE
SOME OF THE ISSUES I KNOW
THERE'S A- AROUND POSITION
VERSUS. FRIENDS WERE WILLING TO
LOOK AT THAT SO- TRY TO KEEP
GOING HARD WORK HERE AND EARN
YOUR GUYS VOTE IN THE FUTURE-
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM FIVE SB THREE SEVEN
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
LAYERED HI. ALL RIGHT JONES.
ALLEN EGGMAN GROWTH GROVE ALL
RIGHT HERTZBERG HUESO LOAN
STERN. STERN BURN ALL RIGHT
THREE FIVE VOTES WILL PUT THAT
BILL ON CALL- WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO A FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY ONE
WITH SENATOR CAFIERO WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. I'M LISTENING
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
DON'T GO ANYWHERE PLEASE. WE
HAVE A GROUP OF ABOUT THE. THEY
GO I'M SERIOUS OKAY THAT'S GOOD
I'M I'M I'M PREPARED SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY ONE THE WATER
INNOVATION ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE. AMENDMENTS I'M A
CHANGES HAVING TO PROVE
PROFOUND IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S
WATER SYSTEMS ALONG WITH AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. GROUNDWATER AND
NATURALLY OCCURRING
CONTAMINATION SUBSIDENCE AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA.
NEW AND INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES
AND MANAGEMENT APPROACHES ARE
NEEDED TO MEET AND OVERCOME
THESE CHALLENGES WALLER'S OUR
STATE IS A BEACON OF INNOVATION
IN OTHER UTILITY BASED MARKETS
LIKE ENERGY. CALIFORNIA'S WATER
SECTOR FALLS BEHIND OTHER AREAS
AND EVEN COUNTRIES IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AND AT THAT
ADOPTION OF INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES. SB THREE FIFTY
ONE WOULD ESTABLISH THE OFFICE
OF WATER INNOVATION AT THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION.
RATHER THAN THE CURRENT
FRAGMENTED APPROACH TO
INNOVATION IN STATE GOVERNMENT
THIS OFFICE WOULD POSITION THE
STATE AS A PARTNER FOR
ADVANCING INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
IN THE WATER SECTOR. THE BILL
PASSED THE STATE TO COORDINATE
WITH THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
IN ORDER TO HELP ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF THE OFFICE. WATER.
TION OF WATER INNOVATION AND
TECHNOLOGY. ESTABLISHING A
DEDICATED OFFICE OF WATER
INNOVATION WHAT ALSO HELPS THE
STATE ACHIEVE ITS GOAL OF A
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER BY
EXPLORING NEW APPROACHES TO
SECURE SAFE DRINKING WATER IN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AS YOU KNOW AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND ISSUE TAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIFTY ONE
ARE DANIELLE BLANCHARD HAYDEN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION IN ADRIAN
COVERT WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL. THANK YOU AND I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR AND WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE TO LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES THE SENATOR
JUST. INTRODUCED TO DANIEL
BOYCE SAID HARDEN AND ADRIAN
COVERT YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES BETWEEN YOU. 2% LET'S
BEGIN WITH DANIEL. WHAT RAISING
SOME MUCH GET OUT IT AFTERNOON
AND MEMBERS OF THE CAN MANY IS
DANIELLE BLASTED HIGH WITH THE-
WE- THAT THE PH AND WE
REPRESENT PUBLIC WHAT AGENTS.
AND ON ELECTRIC UTILITY
THROUGHOUT STATE WE PLEASED TO
CUT. AT THE THAT THE ONE I
SENATE KABIR AND NOTED CALIBER
CONTINUES TO GROW WITH THE- OF
CLIMATE ON THE WATER RESOURCES.
FROM CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
TEACHING IN. PATTERN AND LEVEL
RIGHT. FIFTY TWO SINCE BUT ALSO
BASED MARRIED OTHER TOWN
INCLUDE AGING EFFORTS TO GROW
CAN. THE BATON AND NUMEROUS
ECHO DOWN. IN APPROACH ARE NEED
TO AND THE LONG TRM. OF OUR Y.
SUPPLY. THREE MILLION MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN AT THE BAR OF. A AND
THE TOP A CAT. BUT MORE WORK IS
NEEDED. BY ESTABLISHING AND-
OFFICE OF WATER INTO A THE
WATER. AS THREE FIFTY ONE WOULD.
AND ENHANCE THE EFFORT THANK.
TO FURTHER IN. AND TO TELL. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW TECH. THAT
CAN HELP THAT DATA BILLET. AND
IT SENATOR YOUR OWN A SHE THE
CALL AGAIN WHY CRAWL. WHATEVER
WOULD ADVANCE. OF THE WATER IS
GOING PORTFOLIO. IT HELPS
TESTIMONY I WOULD ALL LIKE TO
SUPPORT FOR BILL I BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING. ASSOCIATION OF.
WATER AGENCIES CALIFORNIA THIRD
NOT SANITY AGENTS. METROPOL
WATER DISTRICT OF THAT
CALIFORNIA MEDIA WATER TO OF
OUR COUNTY RAN WATER. AND YOU
CAN WATER. AND SENATE VALLEY
WATER. WE ARE DRIVING. HOW DID
CO SPONSOR SB THREE FIFTY ONE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT. A SHALLOW CABALLERO
NOTED OVER THE LAST DECADE
CALIFORNIA HAS SHATTERED
VIRTUALLY EVERY CLIMATE RELATED
RECORD GOING BACK OVER A
CENTURY INCLUDING THE MOST
SEVERE DROUGHT IN OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED YEARS. THE WETTEST YEAR
ON RECORD THE SEVEN LARGEST
WILDFIRES IN STATE HISTORY AND
THE HOTTEST TEMPERATURE
RELIABLY RECORDED ON THE
SURFACE OF THE EARTH. TODAY 70%
OF CALIFORNIANS LAND MASS HAS
RETURNS TO A STATE OF SEVERE
DROUGHT. CALIFORNIA'S THREE
TRILLION DOLLAR ECONOMY IS
BASED ON OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SAFE AND RELIABLE WATER TO OUR
HOMES. BUSINESSES FARMS AND ECO.
MEETING CALIFORNIA'S WATER
NEEDS AMIDST A WARMING AND
INCREASINGLY VOLATILE CLIMATE
REPRESENTS A PROFOUND CHALLENGE
BUT ONE CALIFORNIA. IS PREPARED
TO MEET. I ESTABLISHING THE ALL
OF WATER. OF THE WATER. SB
THREE FIFTY ONE WOULD ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO PARTNER WITH
RESEARCHERS ENTREPRENEURS LOCAL
WATER AGENCIES AND OTHERS IT'S
A SOLITARY ELEMENT AND
DEPLOYMENT OF THE WORLD'S NEXT
GENERATION OF INNOVATIVE WATER
TECHNOLOGIES RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. GROWING WORLD CLASS
WATER INNOVATION SECTOR WOULD
HELP CALIFORNIA MEET ITS
NATURAL RESOURCES AND PUBLIC
HEALTH GOALS WHILE CREATING NEW
BUSINESSES AND NEW JOBS. TELL
SHORTAGE TESTIMONY I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. CALIFORNIA WATER
SERVICE COMPANY IMAGINE H. TWO
O. THE NORTH BAY LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND SCHOOL
OUT. THANK YOU FOR TAKING MY
COMMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND THANK YOU
ALSO FOR THE EFFICIENCY OF
LISTING THE OTHER PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT. WE ARE GOING. TO MOVE
TO- SUPPORT FOR S. B. THREE
FIFTY ONE AND A IN THIS SECTION
IT'S THE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION SO IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THIS COMMITTEE ROOM
THAT WISHES TO TESTIFIED
SUPPORT. IS THERE IS SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEE NO ONE OUR
MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINE THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIVE ONE AND IT'S JUST. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER THEY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND THE
GENERAL IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FIVE ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THISTIME
WHEN I GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
ALL THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE OF THREE A LINE IS OPEN.
WHAT DOES THE ABOVE WELL IF
YOU'RE GONNA REPORT ON THE
THAT'S ANOTHER BILL. THANK YOU.
THERE AREN'T MANY LEVEL LINEMAN
ONE. OKAY ADELINE NUMBER ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I WONDER WHAT WHAT.
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA WATER
SERVICE THIS IS THE PART THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
ADDITIONAL COLORS. AND ONE IN
LOS ANGELES YOUR SUPPORT OF
TREES SB THREE FIVE ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR
SHEPHERDS WITH NOBODY ELSE IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO.
IDENTIFIED LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
DIRECTLY- THE TO ANY OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THIS
HEARING ROOM THAT WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY ONE. ANYONE IN
ROOM. TWENTY FORTY. SIGNAL ONE
MODERATOR WERE COMING BACK TO
YOU THIS WOULD BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
FIFTY ONE WITH THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU ONE CAN MAYES GERMANY
FOR YOU IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIVE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE CAN IMAGINE THAT'S
ONE ZERO YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
SB THREE FIVE ONE. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON WE HAVE NO ONE TO
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BRING THE MATTER BACK
IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE. IT
AND- SINCE OUR MANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE RUSHING
TO THE MICROPHONE I'M GOING TO
RECOGNIZE MYSELF IT HAD. JUST A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS- I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT DIRECTION. AND
WHEN WE WERE IN THE DROUGHT
FROM TWENTY ELEVEN TO TWENTY
FOURTEEN- I KNOW WITHIN THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY WE
ACTUALLY ASSIGNED PEOPLE. ARE
HARD TO REALLY TAKE ALL THE
INCOMING THAT WAS COMING FROM
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGICAL
IMPROVEMENTS THAT PEOPLE
THOUGHT WERE REALLY IMPORTANT
AND IT WAS ADHOC IT WAS DONE IN
THE MOMENT BECAUSE- THE MOMENT
REQUIRED NOT BECAUSE THERE WAS
A BILL LIKE THIS THAT SET UP A
PLACE TO DO IT AND- SO I THINK
THIS IS A- VERY. ADMIRABLE AND
A GOOD EFFORT. R. I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT. I HAVE TO THINK THAT
GIVEN THE DIRECTION. WE'RE
GOING ON THE DRAFT RIGHT NOW.
IF OF THE WILL BE A NEED FOR
THIS MAYBE EVEN BEFORE THIS
BILL CAN GET PASSED AND SIGNED
WHETHER IT'S THE OFFICE OR
OTHER THINGS AND- FOR
CONSIDERING A DROP PACKAGE AT
SOME POINT. I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO NEED A TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATION PIECE OF IT. OUR TO
CHANNEL SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE GOING TO EMERGE AS THAT
HAPPENS. AND THEN LASTLY- I
DON'T KNOW THAT THE WATER
COMMISSION IS THE BEST PLACE TO
LOCATE THIS THE ANALYSIS POINTS
THAT OUT AND THEN I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT YOU. WORK AS THIS
MOVES ALONG TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION IF THAT IS
BECAUSE I RECOGNIZE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
A PLACE WHERE THERE'S SOME
MEASURE OF INDEPENDENCE. BUT
SOME MEASURE OF LOGICAL PLACE
TO ASSIGN OF THE BILL WITH THE
SUBJECT. THE WATER COMMISSION
IS REALLY. THEY HAVE DONE A LOT
OF THE WORK THAT THEY WERE
SIGNED TO DO IN IN GETTING THE
STORAGE MONEY OUT THE DOOR SO
IN ANY EVENT- I'M GOING TO BE
VERY PLEASED TO MOVE THIS VOTE
TO MOVE THIS BILL ALONG. AND
THERE ARE A FEW OF THOSE THINGS
YOU HAVE TO WORK ON BUT THIS IS
REALLY NEEDED AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
DOING THIS BILL AND THAT YOU'VE
HIGHLIGHTED THIS. OR THE OTHER
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT WAS VERY NICE FROM ONE.
FORMER SECRETARY TO ANOTHER AND
I WOULD MOVE THIS BILL THANK
YOU- AT THE END OF. ESCRIBIR OR
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR COMMENTS AND- WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD JUST TALK
ABOUT WORK WHERE IT MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATELY- PLACED IF NOT
THE WATER COMMISSION- HERE THAT
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY WE PICKED
THE WATER COMMISSION BEGIN WITH
IS THERE INDEPENDENT THEY'VE-
THEY'VE BEEN LOOKING AT- AT
WATER ALL OVER THE STATE THE
BOTTOM LINE IS WE NEED TO USE
GOOD SCIENCE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND TO PARTNER WITH RECENT
RESEARCHERS JUST GIVE SYSTEM
AB. AN OPPORTUNITY TO LISTEN TO
WHAT MIGHT BE OUT THERE THAT
CAN HELP US TO USE WATERMARK
MORE WISELY SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM SIX SB
THREE FIFTY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
LAYERED BY. ALL RIGHT JONES.
ALLEN EGGMAN. EGGMAN RA GROVE.
GROVE HI HERTZBERG. HUESO MON.
STERN WE HAVE THREE VOTES WE
WILL PUT THAT THE LONG CALL.
AND WE WILL MOVE TO. FILE ITEM
SEVEN ALSO SENATOR CAFIERO S.
B. THREE FIFTY NINE AND LET ME
JUST SAY. THAT IF SENATOR DOLLY
OR YOUR STAFF ARE LISTENING
YOUR NEXT UP. CELLS START TO
MAKE YOUR WAY TO THE HEARING
ROOM- SENATOR CAFIERO YOU MAY
PERCENT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND OMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED 2% SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY NINE. I THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK ON
THE BILL WITH MY STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. SB THREE FIFTY NINE
IS A PILOT PROGRAM THAT ENABLES
MERCED COUNTY AND THE OWNERS OF
A LOCAL NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS. FARMERS AND RANCHERS TO
RECEIVE TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND
INCENTIVES TO STEWARD THEIR
LAND FOR CLIMATE CHANGE AND
MULTIPLE BENEFITS. CLICK THE
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS. THROUGH
STEWARDSHIP AND CONSERVATION
CAN MAKE A MEANINGFUL
CONTRIBUTION TO THE STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS WHILE DELIVERING
FOOD. AND FIBER AND OTHER CO
BENEFITS SUCH AS HABITAT. AND
EMPLOYMENT. TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
LANDOWNERS LIKE THOSE IN MERCED
COUNTY NEED ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO DEPLOYED
DECISION MAKING TOOLS. THAT
INFORM REGIONAL CLIMATE
STRATEGIES. AND LANDOWNER
INCENTIVES THAT ENCOURAGE
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
SECTOR PARTICIPATION. THIS
RESULT RESILIENT MERCED PILOT
PROJECT. WOULD HELP TO ADDRESS
THIS GAP. EXACTLY IT BUILD ON A
READ MALL STAKEHOLDER F.%
UNDERTAKEN BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION AND PARTNERS IN
MERCED COUNTY TO DEVELOP A
CLIMATE TOOL AND AN ACCOUNTING
FRAMEWORK. THAT ENABLES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LANDOWNERS TO
CONSIST CONSISTENTLY ASSESS THE
CLIMATE BENEFITS OF DIFFERENT
LAND MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
ACROSS THE COUNTY. THIS
INFORMATION AND ACCOUNTING
FRAMEWORK ENABLES THE COUNTY TO
INTEGRATE SCENARIOS AND LATT
LAND BASED ACTIVITIES INTO ITS
CLIMATE AND LAND USE PLANS AND
PROVIDES INFORMATION TO
LANDOWNERS ON THE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD ACHIEVE
CLIMATE AND OTHER IMPORTANT
BENEFITS IN THE COUNTY. THIS
PILOT WOULD PROVIDE THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND VOLUNTARY
INCENTIVES TO IMPLEMENT
DIFFERENT LAN MENU MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES ACROSS THE COUNTY
THAT WOULD HELP ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE WHILE SUPPORTING
POTENTIAL CO BENEFITS LIKE
INCREASED SOIL WATER RETENTION.
THIS PRODUCT PILOT PROGRAM
COULD BE EXPANDED TO SAN DIEGO
SONOMA AND SANTA BARBARA
COUNTIES WHICH PARTICIPATED IN
THE RESILIENT COUNTIES PROGRAM
AT DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
WITH ALONG WITH MERCED COUNTY.
SO THIS IS TRULY AN IMPORTANT
PILOT PROJECT AND A BUILDING
BLOCK BLOCK THAT SCALES FROM
MERCED TO MULTIPLE COUNTIES AND
POTENTIALLY TO A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM. PROVIDING TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT IS MICHELLE PASSARO
FROM THE NET THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. THANK YOU AND ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR OF NETWORK TO
MOVE. TO SUPPORT FOR SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY NINE AND WE'RE
BEGAN WITH OF THE LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS MICHELLE PASSARO FROM
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON- I
REALLY WANT TO THINK THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND ALSO
WANT TO THANK SENATOR CAFIERO.
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THE BILL
WHICH WAY TO SHE POINTS THAT
WOULD ENABLE THE COUNTY MERCED
AND LANDOWNERS AND ALL MY OTHER
COUNTIES. TO GOT CLIMATE CHANGE
BY PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THE
PLANET. THE RESOLVER SAID PILOT
DOES BUILD ON COUNTY EFFORTS
THAT WERE STARTED IN CINEMA
ANDERSON COUNTY TO CHIEF
SEVERAL IMPORTANT OBJECTIVES.
INCLUDE ENGAGING BOTH COUNTIES
AND LANDOWNERS IN NATURE BASED
KIND OF STRATEGIES TO GROUPS
THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT INFLUENCE
OVER LAND MANAGEMENT AND LAND
USE ACROSS THE STATE. THAT YOU
CAN GREATER CRIME IMPACT AT
SCALE BY TAKING A REGIONAL OR
COUNTY SCALE APPROACH TO
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION.
WHAT IT WOULD DO THIS BY
PROVIDING LANDOWNERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE TOOLS THE PLAN
INTEGRATE AND IMPLEMENT MAJOR
BASED STRATEGIES AS PART OF
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN. WITH THAT
IN THE STATE UP WHEN THEY
COUNTY GRAMMAR TO CONSISTENTLY
TRACK CLIMATE RELATED BENEFITS
OVER TIME. IN A MANNER THAT
ALSO MINIMIZES THE BURDEN ON
LANDOWNERS. AND BUILD ON
EXISTING STATE PROGRAMS AND
FRAMEWORKS MUCH OF THIS WORK
HAS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED IN MERCED
COUNTY THROUGH THE TWO YEAR
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION ACROSS
THE US. CENTER JUST REFERENCE
THANK WOULD INPUT FROM LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS AND STATE
AGENCIES. BUT WHAT IS MISSING
NOW IS THE FOLLOW THROUGH THE
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL SUPPORT
YOUR SAID COUNTY MORE FULLY
INTEGRATE DIFFERENT LAND
MANAGEMENT AND CONSERVATION
ACTIVITIES IF YOU I'M ACTION
PLAN. AND INTENDED TO
LANDOWNERS YOU'RE WILLING TO
IMPLEMENT SUCH ACTIVITIES. MANY
COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA- ARE
ACTIVELY SEEKING TO UNDERTAKE
SIMILAR EFFORTS INCLUDING SANTA
BARBARA SAN DIEGO. VENTURE AT
THE MCKALE. POSTED NEEDED JUST
NAME A FEW. POLITIKER BY THE
NEW TO FOLLOW PERMITS THAT CAN
AND PLAN. BUT ALSO THE PROOF TO
CONCEPT IS THAT STATE AT THE
END OF THE AND ACHIEVE BROADER
SCALE RESULT IN TOWN ACROSS THE
STATE SO WE THANK WE'RE PROUD
THE BILL AND WE WERE. URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE- YOUR TEST. NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TESTIMONIES. ITS NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION- THIS
IS- SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
NINE AND I'M GOING TO ASK IN
THE HEARING ROOM IF THERE'S
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO STEP TO
THE PODIUM AND SUPPORT. THEN
WE'LL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NO ONE- MODERATOR WILL
MOVE TO THE LINE THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYONE WITH
JUST THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND OUR POSITION IN SUPPORT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR SB. THREE
FIFTY NINE. THANK YOU ONE CAN
LAYS IN GERMAN IF YOU DO ESTO
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE FIVE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WHEN YOU GO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE OF THEM IS ON THE
WITHOUT AMONG CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ME JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE WAIT FOR OUR NEXT PARTY.
NEXTRADIO LINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY SUPPORT IS REALLY FOR THE
BILL HAS ALREADY HAS BEEN- I
KNOW YOU SAID MIND BUT YOU MUST
HAVE A NAME IN THERE SOME MORE.
YES SIR OKAY MY NAME IS DALE
SHOWER I'M REPRESENTING THE
RIVER MORE HILL HIKERS. AND WE
SUPPORT SENATE BILL SB SEVEN
NINE NINE WE APPRECIATE THAT
WERE ON SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
NINE WARMED UP YOUR POSITION.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL. THREE FIFTY NINE.
AND MISTER CHAIRPERSON OF
NOBODY ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. GREAT THANK YOU THIS
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ANYBODY IN THE
HEARING ROOM. ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SAYING NO ONE IN
BOTH MODERATOR WERE BACK TO YOU
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY NINE. THANK
YOU AND ONCE AGAIN THEY
GENERATE YOUR IN OPPOSITION
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHEN YOUR LINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE THIRTEEN. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE FIVE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRPERSON
WITH NOBODY ELSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO BRING THE
MATTER BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AND I'M KIND OF OPEN.
THE COMMENTS AGAIN. AND I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE CHANCE
TO- TO- HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR ABOUT THIS I
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
CREATION OF THE SOCK PROGRAM
WHICH STANDS FOR SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURAL LANDS CONSERVATION
PROGRAM DON'T HAVE TO PUT THE
DOLLAR IN THE JAR FOR THE
ACRONYM IN THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION- AND WHAT WAS
IMPORTANT. IS WHEN THE
WILLIAMSON AXES TO BE. FUNDED
ARE ADEQUATELY AT THE STATE
LEVEL AFTER THE GREAT RECESSION
THIS PROGRAM STEPPED UP. TO
FUND OUR CONSERVATION OF
AGRICULTURAL LANDS AND IN SOME
CASES PLANNING. AND EVEN THOUGH
IT WAS AT A POINT OF- IN
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS OF FORTY
MILLION A YEAR ITS OVER
SUBSCRIBED PEOPLE REALLY WANT
THIS. AND SO I SALUTE YOU FOR
DOING THIS BILL WHICH I THINK
IS IN TWO PARTS IT REALLY.
PRIORITIZES MERCED COUNTY IT
REALLY HELPS WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BUT ALSO HELPS WITH
THE GRANTS I THINK THE
IMPORTANT THING WOULD BE. THAT
WE ALL WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE
SURE EVERY COUNTY IS ADEQUATELY
FUNDED AND THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
TO POUR PRIORITIZE ONE COUNTY
AND- IT AND PRIORITIZING ONE
COUNTY OVER OTHERS MAKES ME
TWIKI IN AN OVERSUBSCRIBED
FUND. BUT I THINK THAT IT IS
ADMIRABLE AND IT REALLY DOES TO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND I
THINK YOU'RE REALLY DESIGNED TO
BRING PEOPLE IN SUPPORT IN
MERCED COUNTY. THIS IS A GOOD
THING I'M GOING TO VOTE TO MOVE
ON THE BILL. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. OR OR GOD
FORBID A MOTION. I NEED TO THIS
BILL FROM BY AGREEMENT FURTHER.
SAN CAFIERO YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE HISTORICAL- AB
INFORMATION AS SOCK HAS TURNED
INTO A GREAT IT'S REALLY A
GREAT PROGRAM- YOU KNOW FARMERS
ARE GREAT STEWARDS OF THE LAND
AND WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IS
FARM AND SO THE MORE THAT WE
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO- INVEST IN THE PRACTICES
THAT'LL CHANGE. HOW THEY DO
BUSINESS- AND MAKE IT EASY SO
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS
THAT WILL RESET RESULT IN THE
BEST- THE BEST. LAND MANAGEMENT
CLIMATE CHANGE- IMPACT. THE
BETTER IT'S GOING TO BE THEY
THEY WANT TO PRODUCE A GOOD
PRODUCT IF WE CAN DO IT AND
HELP THEM TO DO IT IN A WAY
THAT ALSO BENEFITS ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PROTECT THE
RURAL WAY OF LIFE THEN I THINK
THAT'S A WIN WIN SITUATION SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM SEVEN S. B. THREE FIFTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED BY
LAYERED I'D JONES. A ALLEN.
EGGMAN EGGMAN. GROWTH GROVE I
HERTZBERG HUESO MON. AN EARLY
KNOWN SB THREE FIVE NINE HI
LIMON ICE STERN. WE HAVE FIVE
VOTES- THAT'S ENOUGH BUT WE'RE
GOING TO PUT IT ON CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO ITEM ELEVEN SB FIVE NINETY
TWO SENATOR DOLLY AND WHILE THE
PODIUMS BEING CLEANED AND
SENATOR DOLLY IS MOVING TO THE
TO THE PLATFORM BUT ME JUST SAY
THAT THIS IS OUR NEXT TO LAST
BILL WE HAVE SENATOR JONES
AFTER THIS. AND SO- WE'RE NOT
THERE YET BUT STAFF SHOULD
START TO GET THEIR MEMBERS TO
REALIZE WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALLS AFTER THE JONES BILL AND
THAT IS NOT. ALL THAT FAR INTO
THE FUTURE US SENATOR DOLLY
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
AND THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
PREVIOUS AUTHOR TALKED ABOUT
HOW WONDERFUL FARMERS WERE AND
HOW THEY WERE GREAT STEWARDS OF
THE LAND AND I KNOW SHE WAS
JUST INTRODUCING DO SO WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT AND- THE MORE
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I'M PRESENTING SP FIVE
NINE TWO WHICH JUST WILL
ESTABLISH A WORKING GROUP AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IN COORDINATION WITH
CAL FIRE AN APPROPRIATE LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVES TO GATHER DATA.
ON CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
IMPACTS ON THE ECOSYSTEM
BIODIVERSITY AND PROTECTED
SPECIES I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR PUTTING THREE
MY BILLS ON CONSENT I WAS CLOSE
ON THIS ONE I DO HAVE SOME
OPPOSITION WHICH I'LL TALK
ABOUT IN MY CLOTHES. I'LL BE
HAPPY TO TAKE THE COMMITTEE
STOPS AMENDMENTS FOR THIS BILL
LAST YEAR WE LOST FOUR POINT
TWO MILLION ACRES- IN. WILDFIRE
NOW I WANT TO JUST. RECOGNIZE
HOW MUCH THAT REAL IS A SET. IS
SICK HUNDRED FORTY ACRES WICH
IS A SQUARE MILE. SO IF YOU
THINK ABOUT. FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION. ACRE STATS FOUR POINT
TWO MILLION PLUS WHATEVER THE
MATH WORKS OUT TO MOCK SQUARE
MILES OF LAND IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S A HUGE AMOUNT OF LAND THAT
HAS BEEN IMPACTED CAN IT ALSO
IMPACTS TO HABITAT NO IN THE
WILDLIFE THAT'S IN THOSE AREAS
SO THIS BILL WOULD CAPTURE THE
BASELINE INFORMATION TO
UNDERSTAND THE TRUE IMPACT OF
WILDFIRE TO OUR HABITAT AND
WILDLIFE SO THAT'S THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL- HUNTING AND FISHING
PERMITS ARE BASED ON SCIENTIFIC
DATA. WELL WE DON'T ACTUALLY A
CAPTURE THIS INFORMATION TO
KNOW THE TRUE IMPACTS ABOUT
pINVASIVE SPECIES ARE TWO
EFFECTS OF WILDFIRES THAT WE
FULLY RECOGNIZE THROUGH THE
CAPTURE OF THE ECOSYSTEM AND
BIODIVERSITY- I HAVE SUBMITTED
ALSO I WANTED THE COMMITTEE TO
NOTE I HAVE SUBMITTED A BUDGET
REQUEST AND FUNDS TO STUDY.
STUDENTS TO DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. AND I'M HOPEFUL
THAT THAT- BUDGET COMMITTEE
WILL WELL I WILL GET DOES
PASSED AS WELL. AS OF THE GOAL
THIS BILL IS TO BASICALLY JUST
GO OUT AND- I HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIANS OF
WILDLIFE SERVICES. QUANTIFY
SOME OF THE EFFECTS TO WILDLIFE
AND HABITAT FROM FIRE- AND
CAPTURE THAT INFORMATION IT'S
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN. SHARED
WITH A LOT OF FOLKS WERE OUT ON
THE GROUND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHAT THE DEVASTATION IS THE
WILDLIFE. AND THE INVASIVE
SPECIES THAT COME IN
AFTERWARDS- AND AT THE AT THE
PACE AND SKILL THAT WE'RE
LOSING LANDING CALIFORNIA WE
NEED TO GOT TO GET IDEA. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL BASICALLY
THAT O I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE I. ALSO DO NOT HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES I DID THAT
ON PURPOSE THERE'S PLENTY
PEOPLE TO SUPPORT THIS. BUT I
DID IT AND KNOWING THAT- YOU
KNOW HE'S PRETTY MEETINGS GOING
A LONG TIME AND I WAS REALLY
CLOSE TO GETTING THIS BILL- ON
CONSENT AND SO I DIDN'T DO THAT
I DO HAVE SOME OPPOSITION I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'LL CALL IN
NOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE-
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION TO
THE COMMITTEE. THIS WOULD BE
THE OPPORTUNITY WITHOUT IT WE'D
WITNESS FOR. ANYBODY TO TESTIFY
NAME ORGANIZATION. AND SUPPORT
IN SUPPORT. OF ANYBODY IN THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING. SEEING NONE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING NINE A MODERATOR- THIS
IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY
THAT'S IN THE TELECONFERENCE
WORLDS TO INDICATE THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT FOR SB.
FIVE NINE TWO. THANK YOU AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE ZERO IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE NINE TWO. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON OF NO WARNING QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO FIVE NINE TWO
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
IN THIS HEARING MORE. SAYING NO
ONE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SAYING NO ONE MODERATOR
WE ARE VERY QUICKLY BACK TO YOU
IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE PHONE
SYSTEM THAT WISHES TO GIVE
THEIR NAME- OF ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION AGAINST SB. FIVE NINE
TWO. THANK YOU ONE CAN LAZY
JANET WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE JAIL AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE NINE
TWO. MISTER CHAIR PERSON AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q.
THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND WILL BE BACK IN A
BIT FOR OUR LAST BILL OF THE
MATTERS BACK IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE- CENTER GREAT BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN OUR-DAILY FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. THEM YOU MAY NOW WITH
THE HANDLE OFF THE GREAT CABIN
THAT WE LOSSES LAST YEAR IN THE
IN THE CREEK FIRE AND YOU GO
DO. YOU SEE THE DEVASTATION
CAUSED BY ONE OF THESE
WILDFIRES. NO WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY WANT TO REBUILD. IT
DIDN'T THAT LAND AND NOT
WILDLIFE IS NOT GONNA IS THAT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO COME BACK
IN MY LIFETIME I WOULD GUESS-
SO I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC AND I WOULD
MOVE THIS BILL. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION BY EGGMAN TO HAVE
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION AT THE
COMMITTEE LEVEL. SENATOR DOLLY
YOU MAY CLOSE. I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT. I DO HAVE
OPPOSITION AND I WANT TO SHARE
THAT WITH YOU BECAUSE- IT'S A
SIERRA CLUB OPPOSED TO.
BASICALLY THE SEMANTICS OF HOW
WE GET WHERE WE'RE GOING SO I'M
IN ADDRESS THEIR ISSUE THEY
BRING UP- ABOUT THE LOCALS
PARTICIPATION IN. AND THEIR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO- HAVE THE
QUALIFICATIONS SO I'M COUNTRY
TRYING TO NARROW DOWN FOR MAYBE
GOT TO LOOK AT. COUNTY ARE NOT
TO RESOURCE DEPARTMENTS TO
ENGAGE WITH US ON. IN IN THIS
PROJECT GOING FORWARD AND THE
DATA THAT WE GATHER- WILL BE
CRITICAL NOT ONLY- IS IT IS
THIS IS THIS IS ALL CRAWL CROSS
SECTION OF ALL LANDS. AND YOU
KNOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
REPRESENTS 60% OF OUR LAND BASE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK THEY
NEED TO BE A PARTNER WITH US IN
MANY AREAS. IN OTHER CARBON
RELEASE FROM FIRE ALSO THE
HABITAT IN THE- THE INVASIVE
SPECIES IN THE WILD LIFE AS
WELL SO FOR THAT FOR THOSE
REASONS I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MORE YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB FIVE NINE
TO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
LAYERED BY THIRD ALL RIGHT
JONES JONES AYE ALLEN. EGGMAN
EGGMAN RA GROVE GROVE HI
HERTZBERG HUESO MON. SENATOR
LIMON SB FIVE NINE TWO AYE MON
AYE STERN. WE HAVE FIVE VOTES
WHICH IS ENOUGH ABSENT ANYTHING
ELSE BUT WE'RE GOING TO PUT THE
BILL ON CALL AND APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE TODAY. OKAY WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE LAST BILL
THE LAST BILLS. SB FOUR SEVEN
ZERO FROM JONES SO ALERT ALERT
ALERT FOR ARE WE WILL BE
LIFTING CALLS AND YOU WILL BE
STANDING BETWEEN US IN VARIOUS
PLACES IN THE STATE. SO WE'RE
ON OUR LAST BILL ASK MEMBERS TO
GET READY TO RETURN TO THE
HEARING ROOM FOR THE LIFTING OF
CALLS- MISTER JONES SB FOUR
SEVEN ZERO WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ASSEMBLE FOR
SEVENTY CREATES A COMBINATION
OF HUNTING AND FISHING LICENSE
WHICH WILL BE VALID FOR THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS FROM
THE DATE OF PURCHASE. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS HUNTING
AND FISHING LICENSES TO BE
PURCHASED SEPARATELY HOWEVER.
MANY OTHER STATES INCLUDING
NEIGHBORING STATES OF OREGON
ARIZONA AND NAT NEVADA OFFER
ANNUAL COMBINATION LICENSES
THESE LICENSES ARE PROVING
POPULAR. AS MANY SPORTSMEN BOTH
HUNT AND FISH ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS AS BEFORE SEVENTY WILL
BRING THIS COMBINATION
LICENSING AS AN OPTION TO
SPORTSMEN AND SPORTSWOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA. AND BY ENCOURAGING
MORE PEOPLE TO BOTH HUNT AND
FISH THE COMBINATION LICENSE
WILL SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND REACTIVATION
EFFORTS. I THINK WAS PUT
TOGETHER UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP
AT SOME POINT TIME. AND SEWER-
LOOKING FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
THAT I BELIEVE I HAVE A KEY
WITNESS THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO
GET ON THE MAIN ON THE WITNESS
SCIENCE I THINK THEY'RE ON THE
MAIN LINE- FRAZIER CALLING UP
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IT HERE
FOR WE AND I UNDERSTAND CHAIR
THE THERE'S A MAN THAT- I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT IN INCLUDING
THE BILL. THEN LET ME FIRST
ASK- THE TWO WITNESSES IN THE
ONE IS MORE KENNELLY FROM
CALIFORNIA WATERFALL IS THINKS
NOT ON THE RIGHT LINE MARKEDLY
I BELIEVE IS ON THE TRACK LINE
MARK SMITH IS ON THE MAIN LINE.
OKAY THEN LET'S GO TO MARK
HENLEY WELCOME TO THE M.
BETWEEN THE TWO MARKS THEY HAVE
UP TO FOUR MINUTES SO LET'S GO
TO MARK TENALLY. HI MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARKEDLY WITH CALIFORNIA WATER
PROBLEM HM YOU GUYS HEAR ME. WE
CAN HEAR YOU JUST FINE OR KEEP
GOING. GREAT THANK YOU OUR
CURRENT HUNTING AND FISHING
LICENSE SYSTEM OUTDATED AND
NEEDS TO BE FULLY INTEGRATED IN
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY- WITH
OTHER STATES CALIFORNIA OFFERS
RELATIVELY Q. TYPES OF HUNTING
AND FISHING LICENSES. AND ONLY
A HANDFUL OF CHANGES HAVE BEEN
MADE TO OUR LICENSING SYSTEM IN
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS- JONES
MENTIONED AT YOU FOR SEVENTY
WOULD NOT ONLY CREATE A NEW
COMBINATION HUNTING AND FISHING
LICENSE THAT WOULD ALSO. ALLOW
THE LIGHT TO BE BALLOT BOX FROM
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS.
FROM THE DATE OF PURCHASE. THIS
IS A CHANGE WHICH A NUMBER OF
OTHER STATES HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED. THIS WOULD FACILITATE
THE ABILITY OF LIFE INSPIRED
MOST EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY UTILIZE THE LIGHT.
AS WAS ALSO UPON ABOUT FORTY
OTHER STATES HAVE THESE
LICENSES COMBINATION MIGHT THE-
INCLUDING. NEIGHBORING OREGON
NEVADA AND ARIZONA. YOU KNOW
STATE THAT. HAVE ADOPTED THE
COMBINATION LICENSE THAT SEEKS
TO OFFER IT SO THEY BALK AT
GOING WITH THIS- CALIFORNIA
HUNTING AND FISHING LICENSE
SALES WHICH TOTALED EIGHTY FOUR
MILLION IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
AB DECLINE FOR DECADES MANY OF
YOU KNOW DESPITE THE RECENT
UPTICK IN REVENUES DURING THE
COAT AND DEMOCRATS. THIS
DECLINE NOT ONLY CONTRIBUTES TO
THE STRUCTURAL RUBBER REVENUE
AND BALANCE ON FACED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. IT HAS NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR WILDLIFE
HABITAT ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER
CONSERVATION ACTIVITIES
PONDERED THROUGH THESE LICENSES.
DURING THE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE HUNTING AND FISHING
RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
REACTIVATION PUBLIC INPUT
PROCESS. STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT FOCUSED ON
LICENSING THE CIVICALLY
RECOMMENDED THE CREATION OF A
COMBINATION HUNTING AND FISHING
LICENSE. TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
NATIONAL STUDY ALSO ASKED STATE
WILDLIFE PROFESSIONALS. SUGGEST
AN ATTACHED BACKERS. IT MIGHT
HAVE BY AFFECTED LIGHTNING
FAILED IN THEIR STATE. THE
STUDY FOUND THAT AN IMPORTANT
FACTOR THAT INCREASED LIGHT
LICENSE SALES IS CHANGING TYPES
OF WHITE LICENSES THAT IS THE
CREATION OF NEW LICENCES. BY
OFFERING GREATER CONSUMER
CHOICE AND FLEXIBILITY AS YOU
FOR SEVENTY WOULD HELP TO
INCREASE FUNDING AND FISHING
LICENSE SALES AND THE
CONSERVATION BENEFITS THAT THEY
PROVIDE. WE RESPECTFULLY. URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE'RE GOING PICK
UP SMITH SECOND ONE WHEN WE GET
TO. OF THE TO THE OUR PHONE
LINE BUT SHE THE- WITH LOCUSTS
JUST USED UP A LITTLE MORE THAN
HALF OF THE FOUR MINUTES MISTER
SMITH WHEN WE GET TO YOU JUST
BE CONSCIOUS OF THAT. NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO- HE'S NOW IN
THE PUBLIC ON OKAY THEN WILL
WELCOME MARK SMITH OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDES AND
SPORT SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU HEAR ME
OK WE CAN HEAR YOU JUST FINE.
CORRECT AND I WILL USE ARMENIAN
MY TIME AT THE PARK AND LEAVE
DID A GREAT JOB- THE ONLY THING
I'LL ADD IS THIS YEAR IN THE
BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE THOSE ARE THREE
QUARTERS OF A MILLION DOLLARS.
IN ONE TIME FUNDS TO HELP
UPDATE AND MODERNIZE THE
LICENSING STRUCTURE SO FOR THIS
BILL. AND OTHER BUILDING WILL
TALK ABOUT. RUBIO IN MODERN
LIFE STRUCTURE THE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY DOES. HAVE FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO DO THIS VALUABLE
WORK THE LAST THING I'LL SAY IS
ALL HEARD ALL OF YOU TO THINK
ABOUT OUR LICENSE PRODUCT. AS
ITEMS ON THE SHELF WHEN YOU
WALK INTO A STORE AND IT ANY
MARKETER KNOWS IT ANY RETAILER
KNOWS OCCASIONALLY THOSE ITEMS
NEED TO BE REFRESHED. THEY NEED
TO KEEP UP WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN TERMS OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION THEY NEED TO KEEP UP
WITH THE CONSUMER INTERESTS.
ARE LIKE. YOU IN THE SAME
DIRECTION WE FEEL THAT A
COMBINATION FISHING HUNTING
LICENCES. WILL PRODUCE MORE
REVENUE THAN SHOWN IN OTHER
STATES. ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES WITH THE SYSTEMIC
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE CDFW IS
THE LOSS OF LIFE IS REVENUE WE
HAVE ONE MILLION FEWER ANNUAL
FISHING LICENSE SOLD. EVERY
YEAR SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. THAT IN ITSELF IS A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS SHORTFALL OF
THE DEPARTMENT ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
TO CAPTURE MORE PEOPLE GET
INTERESTED IN BUYING LICENSES
IS SOMETHING WE SHOULD
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME STRUCTURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ARE NOW WILL GO
TO OUR PEOPLE IN SUPPORT JUST
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM HERE. IN SUPPORT
OF. S. B. FOR SEVEN. IS THERE
ANYWAY IN THE ROOM TO FORTY.
SAYING NO ONE MODERATOR WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES THIS IS
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BEFORE SEVENTY TRUST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRPERSON ONE
CAN MYES GENTLEMAN IF YOU ARE
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. GOING TO GO TO LINE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT CRITICS OPT OUT WE
GOT A LINE NUMBER SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE GERMAN
ALERTED MEMBERS JERRY DESMOND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI WAYNE KOTO COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXTCODE ALLY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BACK KATHY
LYNCH REPLICATING OUTDOOR
SPORTSMAN COLLECTION A
CALIFORNIA PARKLAND
INTERNATIONAL IN CALIFORNIA
SPORTS LOBBY ON STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
AFTERNOON KAYLEE HAUCK AND BUT
THE CONGRESSIONAL SPORTSMEN'S
FOUNDATION HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR PERSON AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO OPPOSITION. ON THIS
BILL WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO DIRECTLY
TO NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION WE'RE GOING TO START
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS OR
ANYBODY THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SB FOUR SEVENTY.
SAYING NO ONE WORK IN A ROOM
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. SAYING
NO ONE MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO YOU. R. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO- S. B. FOR
SEVENTY. THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR
SB FOUR SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE. LADIES IN GERMAN
IT'S ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR SEVENTY. MISTER CHAIR
PERSON AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M GONNA BRING THE MATTER BACK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE BUT JUST
BEFORE I DO THAT WERE MISSING
SENATOR STERN REMOTELY AND
SENATOR ALAN IF YOUR STAFF'S
WILL TO THE STONE TO GET HERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE LISTING THE
CALLS MOMENTARILY. ON THE
ENTIRE SLEW OF BILLS BEFORE WE
SHUT DOWN THIS COMMITTEE-
SERVICES. BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ON S. B. FOUR SEVEN ZERO. I'D
LIKE TO MOVE WILL MOTION BY
EGGMAN- I COULDN'T GET A MOTION
OUT OF THE AUTHOR. JUST KIDDING
I'M JUST KIDDING. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION- HERE. YEAH SAYING
NO DISCUSSION THAN- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER JONES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
WILL TAKE CARE OF MY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AS MY CLOTHES AND
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THAT'S
GREAT WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. YEAH FILE ITEM FIFTEEN SP
FOUR SEVEN ZERO THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED. THERE'D
ALL RIGHT JONES JONES HI ALLEN
ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN EGGMAN
RA GROWS GROWS HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG ARGUED HUESO ALL
RIGHT HUESO HI A LOAN. ENTIRELY
KNOWN AS FIFTY FOUR SEVENTY AYE
MON AYE STERN. WITH THAT AS A
POTS WILL PUT THAT ON CALL. AND
WE ARE ONLY MISSING SENATORS
TERM FOR THE LIFTING THE CALLS-
WHAT I'M TEMPTED TO NOT DELAY
EVERYBODY ELSE'S SLOTS LEFT
EVERY CALL AND GO THROUGH IT
AND WHAT EVERYBODY HERE TO IT
AND WILL HOPE THAT SENATOR
STERN SHOWS UP AT SOME POINT
SO- THE FIRST ITEM WAS THE
CONSENT AGENDA. NO NO WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE JUST ON CALL OR
LIFTING THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OKAY IT'S THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM NINE
FILE ITEM TEN FILE ITEM TWELVE
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN. FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO
GROWTH. GROUP I HERTZBERG. ALL
RIGHT STERN. OKAY THAT'S EIGHT
VOTES WILL PUT IT BACK ON CALL
SENATOR STERN. FIVE SAYS HE'S
PRESENTING IN HOUSING SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH AND CLOSE
ALL THESE AFTER HE VOTES
PROVIDING HE CAN GET HERE IN A
MOMENT OF TIME. SO THAT'S GREAT
SO THEN WHAT'S WITH THE CALLS
IN ORDER ON THE BILLS WE HEARD.
WANTED TO NAME THE BILL AND
THEN CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM TO SB SIX TWO FOR THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO
EGGMAN. EGGMAN HI HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HIGHS STERN. NEXT
NEXT ITEM FILE ITEM FOR S. B.
C. SIX OH FOR THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
HIGH HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG
AYE LOAN. RIGHT THE LOAN ARE ON
S. B. SIX OH FOUR THAT'S. SB
SIX A FORMERLY KNOWN I. OKAY
THEN WE WILL HOLD AN OPEN AND
TOLD CENTER STEARNS HERE FILE
ITEM FIVE SP THREE SEVEN SIX
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
JONES. ALAN. HEY ALLEN ALL
RIGHT EGGMAN EGGMAN RA
HUESO. LIMóN. LIMON SB THREE
SEVEN SIX AYE MON AYE. I CAN
NOT VOTING. GROVE ARE TO NOT
VOTING. SIX MISTER MISTER. THE
BILL HAS SIX OKAY WE'LL PUT
THAT BACK ON CALL FOR SENATOR
STERN- FILE ITEM SIX SB THREE
FIFTY TO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO JONES. THIRTY THREE
FIFTY ONE THREE FIFTY ONE I'M
SORRY YEAH. I THINK HI ALAN.
BALENTINE HERTZBERG BY BRIDGE
BURKE HI HUESO WE SAW OUR IN
THE MOMENT. LIMON SB. THREE
FIVE ONE NINE ONE HI THAT HAS
EIGHT THIRTY AND IT WAS A NOTED
ONE THING THE ONE BILL SENATOR
STERN WAS HERE FOR WAS HIS OWN.
FILE ITEM FIVE SO WHEN YOU GOT
EVERYBODY ELSE RECORDED WE CAN
CLOSE THAT ROLE AND TO CLICK ON
IF YOU WISH AND BE DONE OF
COURSE OKAY PLEASE CONTINUE.
THAT IS ONE TWO THREE. SIX YES-
SO FAR FILE ITEM SIX IS OUT SIX
ZERO. FOUR ARE YOU SURE. YES
FILE ITEM SEVEN S. B. THREE
FIFTY NINE THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO ALLEN. ALLEN ARE YOU
HERTZBERG BY RICHARD ALL RIGHT
HUESO HUESO ARE YOU STERN TO
THAT STATE VOTES WILL PUT THAT
BACK ON CALL- AND THEN THE NEXT
ONE I THINK IS ALIVE AND RUN.
OF THE NEXT ONE IS FILE ITEM
ELEVEN- THE CURRENT- SB FIVE
NINE TO THE CURRENT VOTERS FIVE
ZERO ALLEN. I HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG HIGHWAY. HUESO ALL
RIGHT STERN THAT'D SEVEN VOTES
WILL PUT THAT BACK ON CALL. THE
NEXUS FILE ITEM FOURTEEN S. B.
SEVEN NINE NINE THE CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE ONE EGGMAN EGGMAN
GROWTH. THIRTY HI RICHARD ALL
RIGHT HUESO. LET ALONE.
GENERALLY KNOWN SB SEVEN NINE
NINE HI. HI. SIX ONE K. SO FIRM.
ZERO SEVEN NINE NINE NO THAT
IS- SIX TWO OKAY SO- THAT
COMPLETES OUR LIFTING OF CALLS
ARE THE ONLY ONE MISSING ON
FIFTEEN JONES IS STERN CORRECT
CORRECT SO- THEN WE WILL STAY
HERE FOR A FEW MINUTES AND HOPE
THAT SENATOR STERN CAN JOIN US
AND WE WILL LIFT THE CALLS ON
ALL THE BILLS FOR HIM IF YOU
CAN. HERE SORRY.
OKAY WE HAVE
BEEN JOINED BY SENATOR STERN
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS
AND I WILL LET YOU GO IN ORDER
AND IN THIS CASE IT'S THE NINTH
VOTE FOR A LOT OF THEM SO ALL
DECLARE THE OUTCOME AFTER YOU
CALL THE DOUBLE TO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
OUTSTANDING MEASURES. LET'S.
OKAY WHICH IN JUST A SECOND.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PREPARED.
FIRST THE USE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE FILE ITEMS NINE
TEN TWELVE. THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
AND SEVENTEEN THE CURRENT VOTE
IS EIGHT ZERO STERN. STRIKE
THAT HAS NINE VOTES THE
CHECKOUT CLOSE TO ROLL NEXT
ITEM. FILE ITEM TO S. SIX TO
SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO STERN. AND I TURN OFF
THAT'S NINE VOTE AND NOT OF
SALE. FILE ITEM FOR S. SIX OVER
THEIR VOTE IS EIGHT. STERN
TONIGHT THERE ARE NONE VOTES
BILL WAS OUT OF THE ONE IS
SOUND AND THE ONLY WAY WOULD
CALL BEFORE STERNECK ITEM OF
FIVE OF SAN TO BECAUSE HE
ALREADY BY ON THE- NEXT ITEM
FILE ITEM SIX S. B. THREE FIFTY
ONE CURRENT IS ZERO. STERN
THANK NINETY NINE VOTES BILL
OUT FILE ITEM SIR AS THREE
FIFTY NINE THE CURRENT VOTE IS.
EIGHT ZERO STERN. TONIGHT
THAT'S NOT VOTES THAT BILLS.
FILE ITEM- ELEVEN THE KERR VOTE
IS. THE ZERO ALLEN. STERN ALL
RIGHT IT'S EIGHT VOTES TO BILLS
SENT WHILE I FOURTEEN AND B.
SEVEN NINE NINE THE KERR VOTE
IS. SIX TWO BOWSTRING ROAD ON
THIS ONE. AND THEN HOPE WE
MISSING SIX TERM. OKAY I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE MISSED ALLEN AND
ONE TOOTH TO NOT AS I THAT
VOTERS OUT THERE WAS A. HELLO
OUR WAS NOT VOTING ON THE OTHER
ONE OKAY. AND WHAT DOES NOT.
OKAY SO THOSE ARE TWO NOT
VOTING. DR EACH CLOSED NOW. S.
B. FIT US FILE ITEM FIFTH S. B.
SEVEN ZERO CURRENT VOTERS EIGHT
ZERO STAR. TONIGHT NINE CENTS
NINE NINE TO OUT THAT COMPLETE
OUR ROW CALL I THANK YOU CENTER
STERN FOR RETURN- WE WILL NOW
STAY ADJOURNED.